crazy videos coming out of the southern
border i've actually stated a few times
now on my show
when you have
illegal immigrants freely going back and
forth into and out of this country with
with no repercussion with no security
with no border control
do you really have a country i mean
let's be real it's not just that issue
you combine that with rule by decree
and the two distinct cultures it seems
like america is just
it's like the collapse has happened and
we're watching it happen now just like
in slo-mo like a supernova in the sky
the light is now traveling and
eventually
we'll see that
the the total collapse there's a viral
video showing a man carrying takeout
see these people come into the united
states illegally
and then they cross back into mexico to
get carry out from restaurants and then
come back into the u.s that to me is one
of the most shocking things this viral
video shows a border patrol agent on
horseback like whipping a guy it's just
beyond insane what's happening in this
country but we do have a lot of other
stories in dc they're mandating
vaccinations for for student athletes
vaccine mandates are being uh violently
protested coveted lockdowns in australia
union workers fighting a lot of crazy
stuff has been going down
and so
we brought in alex jones and phil
labonte to discuss these very important
issues alex would you like to introduce
yourself well absolutely i'm here it's
my third visit love the beautiful place
you're in here in west virginia and one
of my crew members is actually here uh
joey who was just four days ago
at del rio texas and got some of that
footage that's at freeworldnews.tv that
actually shows thousands of people going
back and forth over the spillway on the
rio grande river getting their topo
chico and their enchiladas and things
and going back over uh to the refugee
camp with now over 20
000 people uh that are uh there and and
then we first broke this two days ago
it's now confirmed over 10 000 more are
showing up in rio dosa uh 200 plus miles
away on the texas border of mexico uh
coming across into mcallen texas as we
speak so this is a full-on
invasion uh
you said refugee camp absolutely so
these are refugees fleeing i think it's
an earthquake right well yep i mean they
call them migrants but i mean i get the
third world's collapsing the global
lockdown even the new york times and
ewen admits put
287 million people on the verge of
starvation an extra 20 million starved
to death during the global lockdown
dozens of times what coveted killed and
still has killed
and so yes they're refugees from
globalism from u.n exploitation in haiti
and from the earthquakes and most of
them been waiting several years uh in
central and south america and then when
they saw biden legalizing all these
other people they now made the trek up
here with everything they've got yeah i
feel sorry for them i'm not against them
i'm just saying when they implode the
third world and starve everybody to
death with the lockdowns that's going to
cause in europe and here everybody to
get flooded and just just for the for
clarity it was i think it was a u.n
report that said 225 million predicted
to starve due to the economic shutdown
or is it was it 250 uh
you're right there's been a bunch
anybody can go to youtube and pull up
the
world uh un food director and he's up
there saying we project 200 million then
220 the 250 then they projected that 287
million people as of just a few months
ago are on the verge of starvation they
weren't on the verge now they're on the
line spending 60 70 percent of any
income they have on food they have no
food for medicine then they become
malnourished and died and so but they
estimate the un does and i think it's an
accurate number for them 20 plus million
it's like 22 million extra starved to
death during global lockdown which is
still ongoing in parts of africa
uh and and central and south america
where authoritarian regimes are using it
for control so that's why even the u.n
uh food director said we don't want any
more lockdowns and the special envoy
from the u.n said a year ago we better
stop this but they didn't we'll we'll
get into all that we also got phil
hanging out absolutely good hello
how is everyone doing uh i am phil from
all the band metal band all the remains
uh and i'm excited to be here it's i
think my third time here as well it's
good to meet you alex
i like that shirt i appreciate that uh
so with james lindsay
you know they got a list of drinks
doesn't know how communism doesn't know
how they got a great list of drinks down
there like the free market the
libertarian the capitalist the
communists said is the communist should
it be glass
should be i mean russian vodka i guess i
don't know
we got ian hey everybody ian crossland
here happy to be here with you wonderful
gorgeous humans thanks for coming alex
and phil love you guys
i am stoked for this show i feel like
i'm not going to get a word in edgewise
and it's going to be fine i'm sarah
patrick's i'm pushing buttons in the
corner
here's hoping we don't get banned yeah
well i tried to i told you i'm going to
be more calm on the show because i want
to be more calm but as soon as i have a
chance to talk about
20 plus million people dying because of
the lockdowns i feel like i need to say
that because people need to know they're
calling for new ones and joe biden put
in the new national terrorism directive
policy in june of this year no longer is
the main terror threat al-qaeda uh or
isis or the chinese communist or the
russians it's now officially people that
question the election and people that
question future lockdowns which tells me
they've got more of those planned and
that's in the official policy report
people can pull up and and again uh
that's pretty scary to me because the
democrats always question elections
whether it's a real election or whether
there's a problem i think everybody has
a right to do that so it's pretty damn
scary yeah yeah we'll we'll get into all
of it i have a lot to say i want to just
keep going but we got we got an amazing
sponsor everybody we have
eatrightandfeelwell.com biotrust keto
elevate mct oil powder uh i gotta say
this stuff's absolutely amazing so we've
been we've been shouting out the keto
powder it is the best medium chain
triglycerides that's the fat you want
and i recently i would put my coffee and
stuff and it's great it's almost like
creamer and then i actually started
doing keto about a month or month and a
half ago and i feel like a million bucks
i've been having more skating better i i
used to like i would eat dinner and then
just get tired and groggy cut out the
sugars and all the garbage and now i'm
just maximum energy all day no joke
that's just me that's just me but go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you can
secure your supply of keto elevate for
up to 51 off today they say you get a 60
day money back guarantee keto elevate
provides your body only c8 the most
ketogenic mct that's medium chain
triglyceride in its purest form you'll
get enhanced energy levels healthy
appetite management enhanced mental
enhanced mental clarity which i could
use right now apparently
and um
improve athletic performance keto
elevate is very gentle on your stomach i
don't even know why they needed to put
it in there i put it in my coffee every
morning and i feel like a million bucks
they say you get free shipping on every
order and for every order today biotrust
donates a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year free vip live health and
fitness coaching from biotrust team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and their new
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order again go to eat right and
feel well biotrust you guys rock you
guys when it comes to any one of our
sponsors and they're on board with the
show that we do and the things we talk
about you know they're legit and we
actually have a new we got something new
coming from biotrust recently that they
sent us as a sample we're really excited
for so i'm i'm seriously grateful to
biotrust eatrightandfeelwell.com but
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member
because we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up and i'm almost
laughing because this is where it's
going to get just wild and crazy we can
say whatever we want on our website
youtube's got dumb rules we try to be
careful but we still want to make sure
we're saying things that are true and
important it just means that when it
comes to the timcast.com member segment
you'll see tonight there's gonna be a
lot of swearing so with that being said
uh let's get into actually the first
segment why the show is happening you
see we do want to talk about the news
and the border crossing and stuff but
before the show i was i was asking like
you guys want to talk about like how
this how this came to be and
yeah so let me just let you guys uh know
basically what happened so we were we
were trying to figure out and we're
still trying to figure out good shows to
do
that are kind of
unique we had vosh and charlie kirk and
i thought that was great
it was kind of crossfirey like the left
versus the right nah and it's kind of a
little too on the nose so we're trying
to figure out interesting personalities
that may agree or disagree but not be in
the same spaces in the culture war so
maybe someone who's a comedian versus
you know having a discussion with
somebody who's in finance or getting
someone like you know max kaiser who's a
bitcoin guy to sit down and talk about
someone who's all into philosophy
originally we had reached out to shu on
head who was a big youtuber and she was
super excited that she wanted to do it
and after we confirmed with her we went
to alex and we were like hey alex you
know she was agreed to do the show would
you be willing to do it and uh
alex we were trying to work on your
schedule figure out a date and then once
we finally confirmed alex's availability
shut had unfortunately said that she
didn't think she'd be able to do it she
didn't know what she could add to the
show and it's a bummer because i think
it would have been a really really
really great show and she was really
just afraid to get cancelled if she was
even close to me which again whatever
happened in america we're not the soviet
union
it's good to come on if you disagree
with somebody and have a debate with
them that's what's interesting that's
what everybody's looking for that's why
crossfire used to have 15 million
viewers and now it doesn't exist and
they have no viewers at cnn is because
it's all just orthodoxy the same
gaslighting brainwashing i don't care if
it's right-wing or left-wing no one
wants that plus
you said before we went live and i think
it's true i think she was scared as a
populist she'd probably agree with me
and that's when she'd get in trouble
because you have the character of alex
they put out which is little snippets
out of context versus the real one yeah
so uh basically we were talking before
the show and you know i'm just going to
shout you out ian ian was like we
shouldn't bring it up we don't want to
be disrespectful and i i i can see with
that because i i think i think showing
heads great i think her channel hey i
don't blame her there's a lot of charity
out there and and so you know keeping
your head down might be what you want to
do but when everybody does that you lose
your country you wake up in north korea
like i was saying earlier that alex and
are are a perfect fit together because
shu's entire persona and everything is
built on memes on the internet and and
there's like alex is one of the most
prolific meme creators of of the 21st
century so it's a for her to back out
just doesn't make any sense for her
brand or for you know aside from the
fact that she might get pushback from
some of her more left-leaning friends so
this is where i i ended up you know i
think she's incredibly talented and
funny which is why she has the million
plus or have you know all the fans she
has the million plus views she gets on
all her videos
and you know perhaps she's i don't want
to i don't want to call her lie or
anything when she says she doesn't think
she'd have much to add and she feel like
she wouldn't be participating enough i
mean i think it's a fair point perhaps
but i think she underestimates herself
and then i also think a big component is
we've had steve bannon on the show and
steve bannon talked a lot about populism
and he calls himself far right but then
he says he wants to tax the rich and i'm
like that's not far right steve yeah i
don't think any of the labels i mean we
need populism we need americanism and
that's classical liberalism the left is
not liberalism people study it it goes
back to the jacobins and the french
revolution and george washington said
that is not who we are that's the enemy
they were gonna have nine day work weeks
abolish the family make everybody slaves
it was getting rid of the church and the
oligarchy and the royalty and creating a
total system of control so the left
literally comes out of a super insane uh
cult which was the real illuminati adam
vice and mainline history books and and
they set up the french revolution we're
going to set themselves up as god so
they would have all the science
everybody else would be like animal
slaves and out of that came communism
did it seem like i don't know about i
don't know about it did it seem like the
french revolution got infiltrated well
let me ask you i want to know i want to
address it they tried to kill thomas
jefferson
he was the leader of the illuminati at
that point
and and then he had he had to get out
yes
yes why is so early in the conference
yes
you know this was well this is well
known
george washington this is what i'm here
for george washington wrote
16 letters to pull him up george
washington wrote 16 letters against the
illuminati he said they've taken over
the french they've taken over modern
masonry and i'm trying to stop them our
revolution is is the one that's good and
pure and and theirs is destructive and
he told jefferson you're gonna
once he wasn't president they're gonna
try to kill you and they later turned on
jefferson because i mean you know that
benjamin franklin was not a christian he
was in the hellfire club had big sex
orgies the rest of it and uh
why is this true i found like i felt
like from the library of congress oh no
i wanted to say something first
that you brought up a point about
something i said about shu that you'd
say something populist that she would
agree with and that would be bad for a
lot of these people who are scared of
being canceled to have a clip where you
know alex jones says something about
protecting the working class and this
country and fighting for families and
then having someone spoke to the left
being like you're completely right alex
jones then having that clip go out is
bad for somebody who's on the left right
that's that's the point of me now then
you got into the illuminati and thomas
jefferson i don't even know where we're
at but
awesome
wait wait hold on hold on
so i googled it uh i'm at the library of
congress
and there is a it says manuscript mixed
material and there's a picture here of a
letter to reverend g w snyder mount
vernon september 25th 1798
the street george washington george
washington to william russell i he said
i have heard much of the nefarious and
dangerous plan and doctrines of the
illuminati but never saw the book until
you were pleased to send it to me
the same causes which have prevented my
acknowledging the receipt of your letter
have prevented my reading the book
hitherto namely the the multiplicity of
matters which pressed upon me before and
the debilitated debilitated state in
which i was left after a severe fever
had been removed and which allows me to
add little more now then thanks to your
kind wishes and favorable sentiments
except to correct an error you have run
into of my presiding over the english
lodges in this country the fact is i
preside over none nor have i been in one
more than once or twice within the last
30 years i believe notwithstanding that
none of the lodges in this country are
contaminated with the principles
ascribed to the society of the
illuminati
so there there's more
the point is wow frederick maryland oh
hey yeah amazing
he's talking about mason lodges
all i know is all i want to say is
george washington did write letters to
william russell about the illuminati i
don't know if that means thomas
jefferson was read all 16. i mean thomas
jefferson was the head of the illuminati
that's well known before that franklin
was but they were the head of the good
illuminati then you had adam vice-up and
his jackets take over the illuminati
illuminati just meant elimination and
light and then they wanted to control
the light maybe this is why shu didn't
want to come up my mind is blown
this is amazing alex jones is wrong that
makes sense i mean i have my
perspectives but i'm never wrong
intentionally but i mean this stuff's
mainline history it's just not really
taught in schools but i've read a bunch
of books on it uh that are like written
hundreds like done like um proofs of
this conspiracy and it was that book
that basically out of that they had the
whole anti-masonic uh
party and stuff which i'm not
anti-masonic i mean that's way more comp
that goes back to solomon and egypt and
back then the colleges were secret you
just let anybody in they were called the
mystery schools so it had like the the
birthplace of astronomy and science and
medicine and all that goes back to
hippocrates and all that so there's
these mystery schools that only certain
people can get into and then it also has
a backdrop of the occult and then
christians and people saw it as all
satanic which it wasn't uh because it
all predates christians
society
i don't want to this is a really really
deep subject and maybe people might be
disappointed because i didn't intend to
go off in that direction we were
originally talking about the laugh and i
wanted to come and see how did we get
there because the left is the french
revolution they were co-opted as well
that's right the left the left is not
liberals you were invited out there
to not hear about the illuminati no no
no that's not what happened i was
talking about how labels mean nothing
because
tucker carlson wants to wants to wants
to like rebuild and take care of poor
people and give them actually jobs and
and care about our pop that's more
liberal than leftists that work for big
corporations and hide behind blm but
really don't care about the general
public and help big tech build slave
camps in china left is not inherently
liberal right right so
what i wanted to say was
we reached out to a bunch of people on
the left
and they were very respectful in
declining to come on the show
i think it's because
you mentioned cancel culture that's kind
of what they say to me they're like
there's there's no upside for it for
this if i do this it's just
bad for me right they could sit down
have a conversation with you they get
don't have a conversation with steve
bannon in fact what i want to say was
when we had bannon on the show people
commented wow
i i the media may sound like he's crazy
but he's actually like a normal guy very
well-spoken you yeah but you you you
know the the
the study that uh they study the people
that consider themselves liberal in the
us compared to conservatives and and
conservatives understand the liberals
and just disagree liberals don't
understand conservatives and people that
aren't liberal so right and by
liberalization and they don't want to
understand them yeah
they believe a character of them they
believe
they believe that like
the every
ugly character that you come up with
about conservatives that's what the
liberals believe about conservatives and
that's not the case can i just shout out
one of the most frustrating things was
seeing people play the clip of the gay
frogs thing
without without and they were laughing
at you like you were insane when it was
clear you were exaggerating
a real study about atrazine exactly i
just i mean that's like 10 years ago now
i just read
i just wrote an article about it i think
it was like a uh
what's that show it's not pbs democracy
now yeah democracy now had just had the
doctor on it's like 10 years ago about
atrazine the study and how it made the
males attracted to the males so they
didn't have any eggs so they were dying
out right and it was happening all over
the world with with averaging this toxic
and it was hurting humans as well
studies were showing and very
carcinogenic so i said see i just don't
want them putting
things in the water that make the
friggin frogs game and i said i'm not
against gay people i just don't want to
put us up in the water that makes the
frog's gaze it's kind of a joke at the
end and then they just went crazy with
that well so turning the frogs gay well
so here's what happens i see a bunch of
posts online where they're like i can't
believe he's crazy the crazy thing is on
reddit you'll see people actually trying
to correct people like i get it alex
jones is crazy but he's he's not rock
he's exaggerating but look at the study
and then the people are like ah get out
of here you nut you conspiracy theorist
i will say though you're talking i
believe uh uh updated studies they
followed through found it's
substantially less pronounced or not
happening i don't know the full details
i remember looking into it well let me
give you a second
you're talking about a species that goes
through metamorphosis as part of its
life cycle so
influence from from the environment and
from things that aren't supposed to be
there it's it's completely reasonable to
think that chemicals would have an
influence on a creature that
has so much
that changes so much throughout its life
and and you know it's not that far when
you actually stop and think about it
well also i'm pretty sure aren't there
some species of frog that can change
gender yes i believe yeah so that birds
do it too but but what he just said is
absolutely right because
when they're trying in science to figure
out how to regenerate cells they look at
lizards their tail gets bit off by a
bird it grows back they look at frogs
but we have a little lake on my dad's
ranch in east texas
and he went like a couple years ago to
the to the state and you get carp
uh that have had a chemical put in when
they were eggs and just a few drops of
at the state level makes these big giant
you know carp but they're sterile uh
just from a few drops of a chemical when
they are uh eggs and so that's that's
exactly what he's talking about so this
is wild just i want you you know just
just pause and reflect on the moment um
you know we were we were just going to
talk about how we originally planned on
doing the show with someone on the left
and then within like 30 seconds it was
thomas jefferson was the leader of the
illuminati i got to find out if
robespierre is amazing
did they get to robespierre or was he
actually crazy
do you know much about where did the
illuminati put robespierre in the french
revolution or is he there and they
co-opted him like what because he went
haywire they knew they knew a revolution
was coming and so adam vice hop with
another group of people basically
infiltrated the masonic lodges and and
got control of some of the european ones
trying to control the us ones and then
washington came and spoke out against
them and exposed them but it was
basically before they had intelligence
agencies they had secret societies and
all that was was then the secret
societies got taken over by the
illuminati who said the royalties weak
the church is weak let's overthrow them
and then we'll infiltrate and basically
get all the nobles to join us and a
bunch of the rich people because we'll
have sex parties and supply them with
prostitutes and and and money as well
because there's a bunch of rich people
backing it well so so let me let me just
i want to i want to give you a um
a compliment sandwich thank you sir
all right
you're very knowledgeable on a lot of a
lot of these issues you'll say stuff and
then we factor when it turns out they
they're tr they were true and it
happened on joe rogan's show it happened
on the last show we did with you where
you're like talking about cows and
cloning
and now for the middle part is
when you jump from let's talk about why
you know people don't want to come on
the show to thomas jefferson as the
leader of illuminati is when you start
to lose people
but i'll throw it back to the fact that
you know you can't
if you're right about something you
can't
not inform people because they won't
understand it there's a theory of trying
to in mathematics called proofs and what
you do is you you when you have an
equation you show your work from line by
line and if you just give them the
answer and don't show your work they
give you an f because the whole point of
the proof is to show your work of how
you got to the answer exactly and
everybody else now just says that
person's a racist if they disagree with
their politics show it to me like if you
read my articles or things we show you
links to it now you can disagree with
the links sometimes we're wrong but not
on purpose and where i made a mistake
is i don't know how big my show was 10
years ago or so so there'd be a thing on
4chan or 8chan we'd wargaming oh people
say this didn't happen maybe it did
maybe it did not look at both sides they
can then clip that out which i don't
haven't done a long time and say look he
just said this because i was just
looking at interesting stories so i
learned when q came along i said this is
absolute complete bull to set everybody
up that they're part of a secret society
so they can be led into all sorts of
things and so they don't get politically
active because they believe we've
already basically won the country back
you know if you saw trump as a populist
a good guy and that's all your
perspective and so then i was up front
never even read their theories
on air because if i said those they
would have snipped them out and said i
said that hell they still say i said
attack the capital they still say i was
there and i entered the capital the left
does and it was the opposite i tried to
stop it all so i've learned to be very
careful about what i say because it will
be taken out of context yeah
yeah you know one of the biggest
challenges is when when
you know i read the news all day every
day and then you we were talking earlier
outside we're doing an interview and you
say something about like klaus schwab
and i'm like i have no idea you know i
haven't read that stuff and then the
funny thing is i'm thinking to myself at
this point i kind of learned my lesson
because when you went on with rogan
and he was like jamie pulled it up and
then you were right and then you were
here last time telling us about how were
eating cloned beef and i was like get
out of it that's not true and then did
you just pull it right up oh yeah i mean
washington post writing about it we had
we had neighbors we had neighbors that
owned an a m uh
sponsored lab
system they owned the property it was on
in east texas and they had cloned cows
20 years ago
here's what i think though i remember
you went on joe's show before and you
were talking about like interdimensional
beings and that's the speculation you
know human mutants and 5g and that stuff
was just over over well i was talking
about what the globalists believe and
elon musk came on this that's like four
years ago and then elon musk came on and
basically said that the elites believe
that they're going to become gods they
know they're going to force a human
mutation and merger with machines they
believe that
that they are contacting and that's why
they're taking dmt and government
programs to try to map other dimensions
and see
because
they they're having government events
and corporate sponsored deals where they
have like
iv dripped dmt and i told joe this six
months before you even came out on the
news and i said it was going on the 70s
as it was some people that were involved
in it and they would take like
astronauts interdimensional astronauts
uh
you know kind of like in that movie that
came out uh interstellar where it's
interdimensional there that's how the
aliens are communicating with because
they can't even grasp how it works they
create an interdimensional system he
understands to be able to reach through
and communicate back their time space to
earth to give them the equations to
build a spaceship but but what i'm
getting at is the globalists are
obsessed with that and so they're not
into interstellar travel so much as
they're in inter interdimensional travel
and that's what the aztecs the
babylonians all of them are into but the
only type of entities that will
communicate with us are lower level
because higher level ones won't
interfere in a developing
sub-civilization and so kind of like the
space trash comes in and it's more like
a gremlin and just wants to see us kill
kids and drink blood and do horrible
things because that thrills them
interdimensionally so that's why these
creatures always ask for blood always
ask for children then they'll give you a
little bit of knowledge they have about
what they've seen and done i i'm not
saying i've seen that i'm saying i
believe that i don't i've never taken
dmt i'm not doing that the globalists
are doing that and and and thank thank
you so much for inviting me
but i should shut up the point is but
the higher dimensional ones are
communicating with us but our brains as
radio receivers aren't tuned to the
right frequency to hear it
except we're operating in a lower animal
brain and that tunes
to the demon channel okay there's a few
things i want to say all right
okay wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait so what you although you
could tune to channels he's right and
and the one we tuned to was like
food get warm
when you say globalists there are
powerful international interests who
believe weird stuff
yes there are a lot of powerful rich
people that want to have immortality and
want to explore and one of the secrets
of the universe so they've paid
trillions the equivalent trillions out
since the 1850s to sir francis galton
and others to to to break through break
on through to the other side all right
break all through to the other side so
so that becomes a bit more
understandable right when you tell the
average person that there's globalists
trying to contact interdimensional
beings they're like i'm out well the
nazis had a whole ss castle
wolfenstein what are you talking about
hold on hold on slow down
when you say though there are wealthy
people who don't want to die and they
want to live forever you can then walk
them there like um you know they do the
blood transfusions with young people
they're absolutely paying money if you
go to a poor person i should say a
regular working-class person and say if
i were to tell you billionaires are
spending billions and trillions of young
people's blood to try and figure out how
to live forever would you believe me
they're going to say yeah of course
right what else of course they got
bunkers in new zealand
so uh with that being said
have you ever seen stargate sg1 no so
you would love this show see i'm going
to spoil it for those who haven't seen
it to 20 year old show but uh uh
so there is a secret program called the
stargate program right basically uh long
story short i think i've seen the show
like once or twice awesome [ __ ] the
movie was really good yeah so in the in
the show the stargate it's it's built by
an ancient civilization and it's like
there's a massive network of gates that
you can dial in a certain code and it
opens up a wormhole to other parts of
the universe even other galaxies and the
ancients who built those technology
eventually ascended became so evolved
that they transformed into pure energy
and moved to a higher plane right
right so they're like when in the show
they turn to light and trent and that's
what the globalists believe they're
gonna do so they tell you through their
movies what they think well so this is a
tv show where in the show there are the
the uh the ancients who have ascended
the ascended beings don't interact with
the lower the watchers because they have
a policy against against interacting but
then later in the show there's the aurai
who
try to get people to worship them to
derive power from their worship and they
have emissaries and religious and
priests they're psychic vampires yeah so
i everything you were saying i was like
sounds a lot like stargate you know yeah
i mean i think i've i don't watch a lot
of tv i've seen a few clips of those
like 20 years ago came out right or
something it was like 1997 i think yeah
i mean i remember i don't this is study
look if you read some show if you read
the texts that are confirmed to be king
solomon's that they've now dug up you
know and found
the uh
the hebrew of and and you look at the
ancient egyptian stuff and all that most
of it was not what you call black magic
to be destructive but there were always
schools that were into that who believe
they were talking to destructive
entities that would actually give them
advanced knowledge if they paid them
offerings they didn't want gold they
didn't want silver they didn't want
rubies they wanted human life
and so they wanted to drain
interdimensionally off the torture of
children particularly power that's where
the satanism comes from it's why you
sacrifice children to give the devil
power did i ever talk to you about full
metal alchemists too i don't think so
you would also love that show so uh it's
a manga and anime and there's a lot of
people uh who are like oh yeah full milk
is probably cheering in the comments
because it's a great show basically
what's it called
check this show out you'll like it
basically long story short i'm going to
spoil it for you and everybody listening
uh they someone creates a homunculus an
artificial life form right they use
alchemy to do it this being eventually
discovers that by using human souls they
can open up the gate to higher power i'm
very very simplifying the story for
those truths exactly there's lower level
entities that need us to get higher up
in the ascension that's black matter in
the end they do this massive
transmutation circle that's going to
kill like four million people so they
can open the eye of the moon open the
gate every person has an internal gate
so it's it's it's and that's what the
globalists believe they believe they
have to kill all humans on earth but
before they can ascend uh to to the
transcendence to become like but where
do you get that like where does that
look when you tell me that there's a
letter from george washington to this
you know william russell about the
illuminati i google that and i see it
yeah library of congress.gov has it but
when you say that the globalists believe
in dimensional aliens how do i
fact-check that
well i mean if you want me to dig that
stuff up i can actually sit there and
show it to you and bring your whole file
or email it to you but if you study
the aztecs and the babylonians and every
other culture would go through from
going to be hunter-gatherers
uh to being an agrarian society so now
people sort of building towns and cities
they would always set up a priest class
that would start taking drugs to try to
find you know higher knowledge and they
would get contacted by destructive
entities uh that demanded the blood of
children and women and and sacrifice and
so every culture
starts human sacrifice uh to molecu you
know the winged snake
it's hard to pronounce kawasaki
or whatever one of those with the aztecs
and you know i've been there
that's how you say it and so i've been
down to to chinchin it's i've been to
the other places i've been to some of
the other temples and i've been other
ones around the world and and so every
culture kind of hits a dead end where
they start human sacrificing and
demanding the firstborn just like we see
uh in exodus you know in the in the
jewish talmud of the old testament and
they've historically gone and looked up
ramses ii his dad did order the
firstborn of the israelite males guild
and to his sacrifice to their god and
and so that's the stuff i mean the
metallica song about that angel of death
and so that's death creeping death
that's right and so that's the slayer
i know angel of death is the song by
slayer about joseph mengele what i'm
saying is that is the angel of death and
creeping death yes and and that's the
grim reaper and all that and what by the
way you know what fouchy's last name
means what means the sickle oh wow no
way i swear to god all right
google please let me know all right
we're gonna look at this and the town
he's from it comes the name comes from
the 14th century during the black plague
it means jaws according to this
translation let's see look at the
etymology of the word fauci yeah fauci
family name means in italian uh sickle
and it means and it means one who builds
sickles and one who cuts
and uh but then if you go back to the
grim reaper the grim start carrying a
sickle until in it wasn't italy then
yeah
he's confirmed yeah the italian surname
derived from
jones
did you know do you know about the
extended state dmt experiments they're
doing
uh that's the that's the iv drip yep and
i told joe on that show four years ago
about six months before it came out they
broke the news because i pushed him to
do it that it's not a corporate party
though it's a university university well
i mean i knew because my mom knew people
that were doing it uh in the 70s and 80s
with the cia in in uh san francisco at
this uh big uh
university group you know you know i
guess but i said that on joe's show
before it came out yeah and i was a kid
my parents were involved that they had
friends that were research scientists
and they were talking about one time i
was asleep in the back of the volkswagen
when my mom with her friend was driving
up to uh
to uh
arkansas to you know travel around and
see some cool places and i'm sitting in
the back of the car listening to this
talking about how they're having groups
of people take this having the same
experience going into these dimensions
talking to these aliens they believe
they're aliens but that they're they're
sneaky they lie they're basically demons
they're like clockwork elves so i i'm
sitting the back of the car hearing my
mom drive along with somebody who's you
know i mean they're talking in front of
six seven eight nine years old
repeatedly and they i mean so these are
research scientists in san francisco in
a university study you know at the
psychedelic research institute or
whatever it's called i'm going back from
memory and then it's actually people on
different hallucinogenic drips long term
going in like mapping everything and
then coming out of it writing it all
down what they saw then going back
trying to communicate the things always
say we want you to kill children
why
like that that's where you lose me right
it's like the weirdest thing no i mean
like it starts off with this amazing
fantastic journey of like uh you know
through the through the back in the
world
you go through the back of the imagine
this why do you think joseph mingler did
it why do you think okay hold on let me
let me let me what do
a bunch of children are playing hide and
seek in their in their family home as
their parents are out about working
when young one of the young children
goes to open the wardrobe to go and hide
but behind in the back of the wardrobe
there is no wall narnia and they stumble
hold on they stumble into this amazing
winter wonderland where a giant lion
rise up and says bring me the blood of
children see that's where you lose me
well they want the blood of the lion in
that in that story but i know i know i
know it's like you start off with this
fantastic journey it's like it's like
they want to meet the interdimensional
so you ask for the proof every culture
builds pyramids and starts cutting
children's hearts out everyone almost
every culture the druids the africa has
done it the point is in europe they did
it all over the druids yeah whether it
was scotland ireland what's england
today germany uh the visigoths with
what's what's switzerland today there's
huge mounds and pyramids they're in
china everywhere they get it and they
and they dig into them and it's children
with their hearts cut out in asia too
yeah yeah they but they fixed they
stopped doing that as much about five
thousand years ago they did it first but
the whole point is they always take
lucid chance and then they put
a string with obsidian through their
tongue and then just go ah and then cut
their genitals off well that's that's
the highest level for the aztec priests
and others and finally then they just
commit suicide
to the god while they're on drugs so you
know what's really difficult is when
you're like fauci's name means sickle
and then we look it up and it's true but
then you say that
yeah most cultures finally decline that
free class
the priest class finally kill themselves
look up the aztecs drawing
uh ropes with
with glass through their genitals
i'm not gonna look that up and that's
volcanic glass in case anyone's
wondering i recommend you don't look it
up yeah you know i've got a few right
now no no it's not point
you'll be at the you know madrid uh
museum of natural history where they
have a whole area of it and they have
carvings for their 500 years old brought
back from
from there of jumbo jets with the
windows on it and the two engines
i've got this feeling that that the
energy source doesn't want us to do
anything it's just there and people it's
passing through this this imperfect
filter of the human body where we need
to eat we need to destroy to consume to
survive so it's got this taint and a lot
of really powerful people are using it's
like their own warped perception of what
they think it's
is yes humans could be projecting
because it only hits our lower brain
that what it wants us to do is eat
children so so going back to stargate
right there's an episode where it's
richard dean anderson by the way great
actor he he accidentally gets hooked
into very quickly an ancient knowledge
repository which begins downloading all
of the ancient information to his brain
but his brain is primitive and can't
handle it so it starts erasing his
cognitive functions and then he slowly
can't talk and he's so you know just
kind of like what you guys were saying
you get this this energy from this
all-powerful or interdimensional higher
being your brains can't handle that and
it makes you chop your generals off
okay that's not all that happened no it
also doesn't just say kill kids it says
it tells men chop your genitals off
that's the transmission you get and then
they do a final ritual where they they
don't just draw strings of their tongue
or cut their ears off then they start
they like gouge their eyeballs out and
then slit their throat but so you're
looking back at this the highest level
for the high priestess to finally kill
themselves that's why you had some roman
emperors that killed themselves and
stuff but they'd already burned down the
city you know i would get into these
deep meditative trances in like 2012 13
and i was hearing is i thought it was
god like and i would hear like die die
and i was like what is this voice what
it's like this human it's like it's
vibrating in our atmosphere and it's
like the collective consciousness is
being filtered into words and they're
telling us kill ourselves but that's why
schwab goes you will soon be very angry
what we have done is for the earth soon
they will be angry and they go we're all
just going to rise up and kill each
other they also tell us
schwab's schwab is definitely creepy and
he's probably a bond villain um i've
i've meditated a fairly decent amount
and i have never heard a voice in my
head tell me it only happened between
2011 and 2012. it was a very specific
period of history where everything was
changing 2011. and it must have been a
collective like that is
the least mindful thing that i could
imagine i wasn't yeah experiencing what
i'm trying to be mindful remember the
kingsman though that came out where the
billionaire is going to send a signal to
their phones and make you kill yourself
the movie yeah and that's basically what
the great reset is to get us to hate
each other i don't think i don't think
that's it i pull up schwab says we're
going to have a very angry time
everyone's going to be very angry but we
will fix it soon with great reset which
is they're doing it all right right
overthrow cause a revolution that sounds
very russian i don't
you'll never go back to normal your face
looked like him for a second from over
here i i wonder if you know so here's
let's let's let's let's try and uh
everyone uh it looks like nosferatu deep
breath pull up nosferatu deep breaths
all right deep breath all right phil
keep breathing
so here's i'll tell you what i've said
about you in the past
i thought i was going to be called you
said you were going to become a man
watch this
okay there we go oh yeah yeah you you
you find a story and sometimes you'll
take this this point of truth and
stretch it too much
so like the great reset stuff now there
are temples worldwide where everybody
murders children and women and finally
cuts their genitals off i where's the
proof of that i mean it's everywhere in
every anthropological and archaeological
ancient traditions and stuff like that
and the globalists are obsessed with it
now i mean i mean this whole the
national satan group came out and said
killing babies is our sacrament we don't
know well hold on they're talking about
abortion yeah to use to claim first
amendment religious rights to get around
it like hope he's taking peyote but no
they really mean
that's what i'm saying about you taking
a morsel of truth and stretching it
there's a big difference between a
clearly political group using satan
because it offends christians and then
trying to use that to cl and it's also a
religious symbol i've seen their movie
hell satan they
by the end it's really changing but
these these people the satan group
specifically say they don't believe in
satan they don't believe in religion
they don't believe in any supernatural
entities yeah and they're doing true
the church of satan is definitely just
like edge lords that's really what they
are they're just like okay it's not the
church of satan it's it's it's the other
group that's really political of the
democrats
it's the satanic temple yeah
i think represents them the point is
that's okay they get their first
amendment i get mine but believe me
believe me i've taken one look at those
people and seen their movie and then
they're like yeah we just do this we
think it's cool it's all destructive
they're all very weak they're seeking
after power of this world but so i i
look at this group
and you look at their core principles
and how much you want to bet i'll read
their principles so you'd agree with
them no i know it's human empowerment
and all this other stuff autonomy
individual rights but they support the
democratic party which ain't happening
right exactly no use the one the one
freedom is oh your body but we want you
to have force inoculations and we don't
believe alex jones should have free
speech
ask them so i i look at the uh
they called my lawyer up and told him we
don't
we don't want you to represent alex
jones or we're going to kick you fire
they said fine
temple did yeah i think that was the
group yeah
the satanic temple rep people called
your lawyer or what yeah my lawyer
represents the biggest satan group in
america i mean one of my lawyers i got a
lot of lawyers he's one of the top first
amendment lawyers so you're going to
support people you got to support me you
know right and and and so the issue is
it's like people representing larry
flynn i don't like a lot of larry flint
did but he published two of my articles
that i wrote about 911 being an inside
job
uh and you know in in hustlers so you
know i don't i don't agree with the
whole sex trade and all that kind of
stuff but i'll get my stuff published
where i can just like people should come
on here it's a venue to talk to millions
of people what the hell is it oh who's
there who's it going to be on a bunch of
self righteous sanctimonious idiots the
left today are actually the the
oppressors of information they're
actually the people they're orthodoxy
covering up the horrible evil mega
corporations they run they're totally
cold-blooded and again run slave camps
all over the world we can name all their
names if they want to fact-check all
right
now we're getting back into modern
politics yeah you see so so look i i
gotta i gotta say it
all that stuff you're saying
is awesome
it's funny people laugh oh the
right-wing super right-wing fake
christians will go jones and [ __ ]
lawyers the churches no no no no no no
no the devil and he's with them they do
that crap who's gonna believe you
like you're you you come out you say a
whole bunch of stuff without i could
call my lawyer mark right i'm talking
about i've been mark rondon i'm not
talking about your lord temple of satan
or whatever we're talking talking about
all the accusations you've made about
the temples and the kids and what the
typical
temple of satan believes
i don't i go to their website and i can
read their principles i go to their
twitter i can see what they say and it's
like like phil's saying they're
edgelords when you come out and you're
yelling that they believe this stuff and
they're evil
how do you how do you expect to convince
a regular person when you say the most
outlandish thing from the get-go it's
outlandish that the main satan group in
america is probably not too good okay
yeah but you when you say specifically
they believe acts and i know it but they
don't they did court filings saying it
is our sacrament to kill these babies
and it's a ritual we do and i happen to
know they've that's true
they've said they said part of their
rituals is abortion but i know people
that have been involved at the
abortuaries even arrested several
abortionists because they were doing
stuff i'm not gonna mention on-air with
eight-month-old babies nine-month-old
babies let's experiment remember when i
was on rogan three years ago
and it became a big national story it
was a big national story and i talked
about governor northam in virginia very
near to you here in west virginia and he
was saying well we make a decision not
with law enforcement or the courts but
with the mother whether we resuscitate
the baby that's a legal term of saying
it's not a human then they keep it alive
sometimes up to two weeks to harvest its
organs and i told people they then
deliver the baby sometimes a living to
the research facilities where they're
dissected they have they have the boxing
matches with the babies uh while they're
no this is a video i'm not joking they
have the living babies they boxing match
them and they also have sex with the
babies before they kill them at some of
these places and this has come out in
the news this is this i have not seen
anything we
have videos with them with babies boxing
i have videos and i have the federal
filings there are many are illegal when
they get living babies which would still
beating hearts at the universities and
then it's come out that some of these
abortions do rituals with the dead
babies and have sex with their bodies
you see like the way people treat baby
pigs that work in those slaughter houses
you become desensitized to the life okay
okay so we got we got to stop i'm not
i'm not corroborating i'm john so far
off the rails okay well here's the thing
we can pull up okay let me take it even
further yeah
no we're going to talk about immigration
hey i'm telling you i'm telling you
right now that you saw it come out in
the news last few months at major
universities got babies with beating
hearts and this is what i'm saying i
told you all about it so that sounds
unbelievable because it is we pull up
the stories we talked about him on the
show and the way you describe it is like
10 times worse than the actual story and
it's already a bad story yeah so in the
story delivering babies with still
beating hearts so i said that years ago
the story that was made
said that they were aborted babies up to
40 i think 42 weeks was it right i think
so yeah even though the standard
pregnancy is 40. and we talk about the
news we talk about the revelation it
came out
which university was doing and i don't
want to get the wrong they're all doing
it the big ones but then when you say
like they're having boxing match matches
with these living babies that's come on
man that's that's no no i mean not
there's video of it
well
where do people remember alex jones is
always right no no listen i i listen i
tell you all this
listen this is why she didn't want to
come on the show they had groups listen
shu's mistake i'm glad man i know i'm
glad you're here i'm happy to be here
listen guys i swear to you
you can pull this up if you want i can
send you the video you don't want to
show it on air
that's why they got in trouble they've
arrested some of these people they they
busted people in multiple states i've
seen the news articles for things i
don't even mention on air bro
every culture ends up going down this
road how did we get from like the left
and the right to talking about all this
crazy nonsense well i mean you gave the
reins to alex jones now you're supposed
to be here helping
basically i am here for the ride we were
talking about how like he's like yes yes
exactly
alex jones is going to be there i am
going to get up right let's see let's
not talk about the most awesome that i
have seen in ages and here i am just
like
you're awesome listen listen to this
major big tech companies are the main
users of slave labor of uyghurs three
million of them including buddhist and
christian are also held in china it's
all been in the news many years ago now
it's all mainstream news and these very
groups lecture us about what words we
use or our speech and oh you know this
one company that's simple as an apple
with a bite out of it says oh alex jones
has been curated off the internet it was
the right thing to do last time i
checked i didn't lie about wmds in iraq
i didn't run slave camps in china with
suicide nets around the buildings and so
we're having trouble believing that some
of the people that do abortion some
doctors that do abortions believe in it
they think it's a service i can see
their perspective and and and they've
got a hard job okay and i've paid for
abortion so i'm not a hypocrite in this
many many years ago and i haven't done
it since and i've repented of it the
point is i don't blame people that are
deceived about it or don't understand
the big picture or poor or scared or
whatever
god judges the heart
what i'm telling you is is that i've sat
there and looked at the news articles
where they arrest
these some of these abortionists because
their own nurses will blow the whistle
on them and they're just doing ungodly
things because some people that want to
be there killing babies or killing
fetuses all day long
some of them are into sick freaky stuffs
what i'm saying okay it's like
somebody's water houses let me tell you
this is one of the pro i have a video i
talk to a lot of people a lot of
different political beliefs and a lot of
people who like to say you know this
group is doing that and i'm like instead
of saying
this particular group does this thing is
it possible to say that the person who
does this thing happens to be part of a
particular group i think that's totally
reasonable i think a lot of the
satanists get into it to be edgy and to
say hey we're super libertarians the
square by telling us what to do we're
going to be shocking but i'm also
telling you that there are a lot of
predators and sickos that get involved
in those groups and anybody getting
involved that's crazy there was a
huffington post article
like uh six months before anybody even
came out uh
who's the who's the actress that first
exposed weinstein now she's all over the
place
rose mcgowan yeah rose mcgowan six
months before rose mcgowan went public
i said
about harvey weinstein and people like
him in hollywood that they abuse and do
all sorts of stuff to women because i've
been told about it but people that were
involved and saw it and i said they have
cults where they brand women and all
this other stuff in new york i've been
told by people that i know they're very
high level hollywood and then it all
came out six months later i i talked
next to him i talked about harvey
weinstein ten years before anybody else
did so this stuff's actually out there
it comes out in court cases that come
and that's what i cover but so a lot of
these stories that we have we eventually
do expose like nixium for instance it's
you know weird and creepy
but
well it's a gateway into things they
were they were get they were dominating
and controlling women for their money
and they were teaching them to starve to
death and not even have enough calories
to be able to think straight so they
could then be turned into
intelligence operatives to infiltrate
other rich people and suck their money
so that was just purely turning women
into zombies to to to uh uh you know use
them as slaves do you know who nikki
klein is i've heard the name she's been
on twitter she's been outspoken about
this a lot of people on the right
retweeter she was a part of nixiam and
she says it's all manipulation and fake
news the media's lying for sensational
story and all that stuff well and i
guess harvey weinstein's nice too well
she didn't say that but i mean it's all
part of the same it's all people get
into that hollywood and things
a lot of them not because they want to
make art or whatever uh like orson
welles uh they they get into it because
they want to dominate and control people
and that power over people and so i'm
not saying everybody in hollywood's evil
i'm just saying you look at what the art
they put out and what they do it shows a
very sick mind
so we i actually was at um i think was
that cpac i think it was cpac i'm not
sure maybe it wasn't but i met some
people from nixium at the time i didn't
know what nixium was i don't they
weren't particularly prominent but they
had a news organization called the knife
they called it the knife of socrates i
think that's what it was and they said
their goal was to fact check the fake
news to stop the lies
that was their organization later we
found out oh these are part of the
nixium cult like all that news that was
coming out they called it the nixium
cult and now nikki klein has become
particularly prominent speaking out
saying the media lied about everybody
they're manipulating everybody it's fake
news well that's again just because the
media you were saying before the show
just speak and you were saying it just
because some of the media lies doesn't
mean everybody that says oh i'm good
because the media lies doesn't mean
they're good right i mean i mean when i
tell you the stuff i just told you i
could dig up the articles about stuff
like that i could send you the footage i
think we should talk about america yeah
let's not talk about negative stuff
anymore yeah we we we we tried starting
off with just talking about modern
political issues
the next thing i
next thing i know thomas jefferson's
leading the illuminati i know right
did you look up aztec priests would
would drag ropes with obsidian through
them we're already at the list alex
oh you're so far off of what we can
actually discuss in in in depth when you
talk about that stuff oh well let's talk
about how you
how you moved out here and how it's
great and the exit is out of the big
cities and how people are taking power
back into their own hands uh and how
this whole
forced vaccination movement is about a
global
id they're going to tie the carbon taxes
to totally control us you need a
powerpoint you know what i mean to do
like a five-hour
step one step two step three i agree
show the articles because right now i
can just tell you i hear a bunch of
stuff that that's like so far out there
i can't even fact-check or i need a
crystal ball look at that
quartz crystal this is your secret power
hydroxyapatite vibrating alongside those
crystals
i'm just saying
how about that border oh yeah oh my gosh
let's let's let's let's talk about uh
what's going on
i want to preface this i'm generally an
open borders kind of dude like i really
think that there should be
getting into the u.s should be a lot
easier there should be there shouldn't
be
uh the waiting list and stuff like that
it should be easier
i do think the us has the right to to
say we're going to accept these people
and or accept this person and not accept
this person um
but what's going on at the border that's
that's a lot of people that are in a
precarious situation
living under a bridge like that's rough
so oh and more more caravans have shown
up yeah so uh
yeah we the the guys from fox down there
are putting up more and more videos
they're just people just walking in tens
of thousands showed up in renosa 200
miles away going to mcallen is is the is
the biggest part of that story or this
story is it the people coming uh to the
border that are you know being
essentially just disregarded by the
the federal government or is it
the federal government's response is it
the faa saying that you can't have
drones in the air
and yeah and the fact that that he
reversed it though kamala harris had
talked about being in charge of the
border and has has not been down there
to look at this at all uh i i really
feel like
as much as i feel for the people that
are at the border and stuff i feel like
the big part of the story is the
administration's lack of a response
unpreparedness um and i mean honestly
ineptitude
ineptitude is even the right word
because they know there's a problem and
they're not doing anything about it now
you've got this video of these uh these
border patrol guys on horseback and one
guy was apparently like whipping one of
the it was a lasso it was a lasso that's
what i thought it was i thought it was
like trying to laugh it's crazier
it's crazy but it's better than whipping
oh for sure
here's the deal in russia you cross the
border they shoot on north korea i'm not
saying we should shoot these people but
you have to understand the third world's
collapsing it they already broke
europe's borders the very same u.n group
that's what's directing this and it's
beyond uh just uh scientific neglect on
purpose to bring five sentences in and
we're we're edging real close to
illuminati
you start talking about the eu and i
know where you're heading
i know where you're headed i'm giving
you all the real knowledge
here's what happened biden in march
early march of 2000 said if i win the
election immediately surged the border
and then now they've basically been
letting everybody in they say they have
flights to border people it's barely
happening they're letting in
unaccompanied men they're letting
criminals he didn't say that verbatim
like what are those exact words he said
if he said he said he said when i win
the election
all of you that want to come to the
united states as as refugees immediately
surge the border just type in biden
biden called for migrants to immediately
search the border there's a video it was
in the debate with trump and he also did
a press conference and said it again
yeah but kamala said don't come
and then they meme the crap out of it
that was after that it was also a
chicago tribune article about it it's
important to look at
the response that is important because
we're americans we have control we have
some semblance of control but also the
just the fact that economic migra when
economics start to falter you're going
to see mass surges of immigration
migration which is extremely dangerous
for a species so we got to look at it
systemically let's uh let's fact check
you alex he thinks he can come on this
show and start spouting these things as
if we can't fact-check the guy okay alex
how about this from the chicago tribune
biden called for the border search
i got the audio right here i know i have
it it's always right yeah
not always right i make mistakes here we
go we got some oh here we go lately
it's out of context but he's talking
about the southern border no that's what
you're saying it's not kind of oh
let me just read the quotes yes so i i
google searched it chicago tribune
ramos are you prepared to say tonight
that you and president barack obama made
a mistake on deportations why should
latinos trust you
biden answered criticizing donald
trump's handling of migrants saying
quote i would in fact make sure that
there is that we immediately surge to
the border all those people people see
are seeking asylum they deserve to be
heard that's who we are we're a nation
that says if you want to flee and you're
fleeing oppression you should come
flee they did and the article goes on
and come they did surging some came
wearing biden t-shirts reading biden
please let us in
and again it's one thing if you're a
real refugee they just call everybody
that gets their legal i've had my team
down there and i've been down there
three times this year my team's been
down there like 10 times at least and
we're going back i mean it is literally
road warrior i mean it is crazy town and
let me tell you
the board patrol get shot at they get
attacked they get told okay at least
stop people and put them under this
bridge or over here and so yeah how do
you stop people when you're in swamps
and weeds and they're running through
with a bag on their back you're supposed
to stop them and so the guy's got a
lasso that's a desert down there it's
not a swamp
uh what's the rio grande river it's it's
it's it's i promise you're river i i was
just there okay he's fact-checking me
i mean it's a dead texas is is well
yeah you're right you're right it's like
a 300 mile border
with mexico and by the time you get out
west it's totally big ben's beautiful it
looks like a spaghetti western but
that's our big it's like california has
a valley it's called the valley and it's
it's a lot of it's big trees swamps
rivers
onions
onions strawberries
potatoes are grown down there that was
just so random big trees swamps onions
potatoes
onions are awesome
grapes uh citrus lemons limes grapefruit
i mean it's farmland it's the third
largest citrus producer in north america
so you got florida and california
california then florida then third
largest is the is the rio grande valley
you know you know what i think we're
going to do here i think we're going to
check the rio grande valley third
largest citrus producer in the united
states we're going to we're going to put
on a couple onions in a pot every day
just to get those caramelized onions
just throughout the day you know they do
that at diners yeah i think we should do
that no but seriously i'm gonna be quiet
for five minutes now
coffee yeah texas is the third largest
producer citrus yes it's texas
they say that texas is the third largest
producer of citrus majority of which is
grown in the rio grande what what's that
stuff you take to fall
can you asleep
get alex a melatonin
i told you we're the third largest
citrus producer i get what he thinks
everybody thinks they think they think
it's a desert half of it's a desert no
no no no i'm just saying that you're
like i think you're already caffeinated
but see they think i'm making this up
i'm not
you know what i'm saying is reality is
way crazier people know
that's true
yes and no
i think reality is fairly routine and i
think people want to believe they live
in a magic like there's a fantasy
there's an adventure there's a there's a
dragon they got a slay and in reality
it's like you wake up you
tend to your chickens and your tomatoes
you eat them i agree that the farmer way
is the purest way but then farmers have
to get together go to war because the
goblin forces sometimes go over the hill
and attack you that's why we have
freeworldnews.tv i've noticed this
phenomenon when people get super rich
like billions and then they start to
like get rudderless like what what else
is there to do and then their minds
start to wander and i hear like very
very wealthy people get into the occult
because of this like they're just like
they look for like out there like oh it
re it's real so i don't put anything
past what's crazy
can we
can we just not deviate off of i like
facts and proof we're talking about with
borders and the republic and the
strength of the union and uh so anyway
so i feel like sometimes to the breaking
of the border by design i feel that
sometimes people get rich they start to
wonder about like what what is there to
do and then they become grandiose
megalomaniacs who think they can use
their money like jeff bezos divorces
wife mackenzie bezos puts billions of
dollars into critical race theory and
other insane ideologies well that's to
create division and enslave us when that
whole act is oh we're liberal we love
you but then they take their money
offshore and basically pay almost no
taxes but then they fund critical race
theory because they're hiding behind
black people if you see all the main
corporate sponsors now it's black people
people oh i want to be nice to black
people no that's a big giant ruthless
corporation behind that
actually i saw i don't know if you guys
saw that black lives matter was actually
going to protest that store
where the hostess got into a fight with
those with those black women
so did they did they you said they're
going to or do they they announce the
protest are they going yeah so hank
newsom he's the black lives matter guy
in new york announced they're going to
be protesting this was it called
carmen's or something yes so basically
there were five women i think they were
all black women and they tried to go
into a restaurant the hostess apparently
told them their vaccine cards were not
real now i believe that hostess was
probably wrong and i believe she was
being racist i genuinely think this
because if their vaccine cards really
were fake don't you think after the
fight the cops would have checked and
been like whoa forgery cards you're
under arrest they didn't do that here's
what i think you see that viral video of
the black family and they're getting
checked by the bible in
because they don't have the vaccine card
but he points out while he's filming
he's like all these other people you
didn't ask any of them for their vax
cards
i believe it because they keep saying in
new york that uh uh
the black community is the least likely
to be vaccinated because of tuskegee
they don't trust the government but
regardless of that they keep saying in
the press the black community are the
least likely to be vaccinated so what
happens racial profiling you're right
there's this restaurant and some black
women show up they say here's our vax
cards and the lady says no that's fake
you can't come in because they've
already basically demonized i agree i
think black folks are very very smart
not to trust uh medical tyranny when
something's being forced on you i think
their instincts are right no but these
are women who were vaccinated i i
understand and the restaurant i was
talking about that was about the black
family well they said a religious
exemption yeah but but uh oh by the way
have you heard now uh biden is talking
about
they will decide what's a religious
exemption and not congress shall make no
law respecting the establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof well that's the first
amendment no no i'm sorry biden is the
sovereign he he he decrees and it is so
can you repeat the great thing when i
interview you today for my own little
podcast which
out there in your green room when i
entered your actual natural world you
mean great points you made about biden
are true the three ways he's becoming a
dictator well so i said that the
republic has fallen uh and it's it's i i
did say this on my show earlier but
those that didn't hear it so
there's there's there's it's hard to
know exactly where the line is when you
can say the republic has fallen but i
think we can see it now and the way
describe it is like a supernova you uh
it happens and we don't know for how
many millions of years until the light
finally reaches us oh look a supernova
happened 10 years 10 million so the
collapse happened and now we're
gradually the light is making its way to
us but it already happened so let me
explain it exactly the borders are
collapsing
right so the first thing i'll i'll say
is keep in mind the borders but before i
get to the borders i'll say this and and
everybody who watches probably heard me
say something similar but
we are there there is no separation of
powers anymore joe biden violated uh the
separation of powers bypassing congress
by enacting the first eviction
moratorium which stood for like was like
a year basically where the cdc says
you don't have to pay your rent but most
people only have one rental property and
they go bankrupt right don't these are
retirees so what what biden did with
that executive order was effectively
seize private property from the public
without any resistance at all and no
checks but so that bypass it's an act of
congress the supreme there's a lawsuit
the supreme court says biden this is an
illegal ruling you can't do it so you
know biden did
i'm gonna reenact it again anyway thus
bypassing legislature twice
and the supreme court but he did it
again with the new osha rule in the
vaccine mandates once again the
sovereign has decreed and everyone in
this country not everybody most of these
businesses just go along with it which
makes it criminal bullying well let me
let me let me get to the the better
points what can you do
you as a compliance you as a peasant can
petition the courts and say i have been
wronged by the sovereign decree and if
the court agrees with you being wronged
they perhaps may tell the sovereign try
again and he does it again and he does
it again and what did the democrats do
the democrats are trying to use a budget
bill to give citizenship to non-citizens
now the senate parliamentarian says you
can't do that and what does the left say
the senate parliamentarian is is wrong
and it's tyranny i don't know i think
the senate parliamentarian does sound it
sounds crazy that someone can be like
you can't pass a bill but for the
democrats to be like instead of
negotiating with the republicans because
they're the minority and we don't have
to they use workarounds because we have
two distinct cultures in this country
fighting for centralized power and a
sovereign at the top who's ruling by
decree how do you know the republic has
fallen with all of that being said
illegal immigrants are walking back and
forth between the southern border for
carry out when it can be so casual they
can go to get tacos and then walk back
into the us and then go back for tacos
again the next day there's no border
there's no jurisdiction the the the
president is ruling by decree in
complete defiance of of our laws our
norms or traditions and the left says
the rights radicalized for rejecting it
while they support rule by decree from
cuomo you know from wolf from gretchen
whitmer from from newsom and they and
they re-elect newsome so how do we
counter that well i don't know how
familiar you are familiar you are with
uh james lindsay's work at new
discourses but he talks a lot about um
an essay by a guy
named herbert marcuse um and i think it
was called uh was it uh i forget the
name of it liberal tolerance or not not
liberal tolerance that was a book by
jonah
jonah goldberg i think
repressive tolerance that's what it was
and essentially
um
it's it's the thought process that the
left generally says that anything that
is done
by people of the left is acceptable and
they'll make excuses for it and the
right anything that's done by the right
has to be
shut down even before there's any action
taken so even conversations about what
would be considered right-leaning ideas
those must be shut down and anything
that the left does that's why you saw
all last year antifa and the riots that
were going on throughout the us the
whole of the liberal media and stuff was
making making excuses mostly saying it's
okay because it was it was it was from
the left mostly peaceful and then yeah
exactly and then anything that the right
does
is made to seem as
terrible as possible and and that's part
of why anything that donald trump did
got enormous amounts of criticism
january 6 is a great juxtapose because
that was wrong what happened a few
people got out of hand i've said it was
wrong day one but then they're like
saying whoever says demonstrations are
peaceful and go out and harass people go
out and attack them they said that and
then i'm there trying to stop people and
the left are putting bounties out to
have me arrested that's right cuomo yeah
chris cuomo on cnn right who says this
protest got to be peaceful and that dude
was like yeah it's the first amendment
but maxine waters had said the same
thing go out and harass uh politicians
and go to you know go and harass them
when they're eating or whatever and that
has always been minimized and
said oh people say oh it's okay or it's
not that big of a deal or they make
excuses
that book that was in defense of looting
all that stuff has been all of this is a
pattern that's undeniable that's that
makes it very clear that if you are of a
left-leaning uh opinion or if you're in
service to left-leaning goals it is okay
whatever you want to do it's there
you're not going to get criticism you're
going to have the vice president raising
money to help bail you out so here's the
question that's what that's come on
here's the question where does that go
then
why is the establishment and the big
corporations funding that move what are
they planning to do what are they
wanting out of this
i think that that really what it boils
down to is it's the easiest path to
uh authoritarian some type of
authoritarian control or more power to
the federal government we've got the
largest government in human history and
you if you think that that the
government isn't interested in affecting
what you're allowed to think
because that's what they're that's what
they want to destabilize things and have
a limited civil war so then they crack
down on everybody
not only that but you look at look at
what happened with with nicki minaj
recently right so she says things that
are either off the wall or wrong or or
whatever and the white house is reaching
out saying we'll have someone why on
earth would the world so afraid of
somebody having free speech and of of
why would they be why would they
make time for
someone that has a bad opinion or a
wrong opinion that they'll actually have
the white white house reach out to them
obviously it's because she throws a
wrench in the narrative that they're
trying to promote but the idea that the
white house is so interested in trying
to control what people think it's very
un-american and very dangerous it's
really dangerous i agree totally it's
very very dangerous and you brought this
up before and and suddenly before we
came up here and this is something i
didn't even know about
because i read a lot of news and i heard
people saying did you hear how certain
people at my office like a week ago alex
talk about how facebook they're like
handing me piles of papers and i was
busy didn't read it how facebook has
five plus million people that are that
live under other rules than the other
three billion people that are on there
so you told me i looked it up there's
the wall street journal how there's a
secret elite who they have speech but
nobody else does
yeah we gotta hear from uh cnbc facebook
shields millions of vip users from
standard moderation protocols they would
have to
if if uh you know we we we've been
talking a lot about tack behind the
scenes for free because they can
override the sensor because they have
their own platform well so it's if you
want an outcome if you want to control
for an outcome then it can't be truly
random so we were talking about like
lotteries
so lottery games scratcher tickets
they're not random they can't be so
there has to be an algorithm an
underlying algorithm because if if you
want to control for the outcome and make
sure only x amount of people win so you
retain more money than you spend it
can't be random sure the house always
wins in the end so when it comes to
facebook and guarding the vips it's
really simple
they need a certain set of political
discourse they deem acceptable the
controlled outcome but of course these
people are going to say things that are
breaking the rules which is why on
twitter it's very obvious on twitter the
left breaks the rules over and over and
over again but it's acceptable so
twitter is doing the same thing facebook
does when we learn that facebook as vip
users should i be surprised it was what
three almost was over three years ago i
showed vijaya guy and jack dorsey
themselves the antifa account that was
like go here and do these things and
they were like we're not taking it down
like they left it up they do they banned
people who responded to it but the tweet
from the left calling province was
allowed to remain and isn't that the
ultimate form of bullying when you've
got big corporations with paramilitary
groups up firebombing things and then
they tell people that aren't even i'm
not even thinking of myself as a
conservative i don't think you do is
like kind of a what mainline kind of
populist liberal journalist and then you
look at them and they're all wrapped in
this mantle they control everything and
they're going to keep you safe while
they've got factories with suicide nets
around them and it's just it's just it's
preposterous
and then the cnn's and and the new york
times says i should be banned for stuff
i've said out of context but they
purposely lie about wmds and then
millions of people die from starvation
there's two things to consider
uh two potentialities
if it's true that there is a cabal that
has as much power as they do and they're
running things for a specific reason why
would this show be allowed to exist
well that's because still a lot even
with establishment or fro or pro free
speech and this is a process the last
time i was here you actually taught me
something really smart and if you go
back to that dialectic you were
discussing about how there's a wheel and
how the reason you're being left alone
right now is because they haven't moved
the wheel yet until you're not
acceptable and then it's the next group
the next group so i was the guy
four years ago they taught us has got to
be banned and then and and then you know
down the road it'll be you that's why
you're smartly building your own
infrastructure your own plan joe went to
spotify to do kind of the same thing
i've done the same thing with band.video
which they've banned that link so it's
free world news dot tv and and so that's
really the renaissance is always moving
away from the empire trying to set
something up free or it's always free
for a while and then we become what we
ran from
yes so the other point i was going to
say is
that
well so there's actually i'll say
another point on that but i was going to
say there's two things one is
why would they allow this to happen well
it's it's one potential potential answer
is that as i described it to you last
time for those familiar there's a wheel
and you've got right wing center right
centrist center left and left
and when i started they called me left
wing even with the same opinions i have
now like saying like i like universal
health care i think there's problems
with implementing it i'm pro-choice my
political opinions are relatively the
same then all of a sudden they started
calling me a centrist now they're
calling me right wing
you're you've been banned steve bannon's
far right tucker carlson's now far right
eventually the wheel will turn again and
i'll become you know far right and then
once that happens they just they lop off
the one side and then it's nazi at the
end but the other
the other potentiality is
uh i don't know i don't know the quotes
from i don't know if it's michael's
michael mouse's quote if uh if they were
winning the propaganda wouldn't be
necessary oh i totally agree listen they
can't do too much and turn us all
against them and that's already kind of
happening so that's the real answer and
there's also different power structures
in the elite there are billionaires and
people out there that aren't tyrants and
they believe in america so it's really a
handful of really ruthless select
corporations
that
klaus schwab used to run the bilderberg
group and i remember it wasn't until 10
11 years ago the media would even admit
bilderberg group existed people say alex
that's a weird thing and then he went in
the s davos which is the public arm of
that and he used to run the u.n
biological diversity system so he's
really the head of the u.n program
and so it's a corporate takeover through
fake leftist ideas the crazy thing to me
is that during occupy wall street
bilderberg was a conspiracy theory yes
and then a few years later it was like a
bulldozer bilderberg who cares you know
it's whatever well they got smart
instead of just denying it existed
because we i mean i remember the new
york times like 12 years ago we were
meeting in chantilly virginia bilderberg
we stayed in the hotel till they closed
it the king of spain got there they
saluted him i got out and there were
marines they're guarding and playing
clothes and they flipped out that
helicopter's secret service so they went
to my hotel threatened me all this stuff
it was insane uh pulled a fire alarm on
and said we did it at the other hotel we
were staying at did it one at the one we
were there it's a long story the new
york times
said alex jones was in a field in
virginia imagining helicopters and men
with sunglasses i put out a film called
in game that showed all the footage in
multiple countries took me four years to
make in europe and canada and then in
the u.s put the film out and they're
literally the new york times saying
jones is insane having a full-on
hallucination at a chantilly virginia
conference hotel
okay so i mean i have i mean i'm seeing
the king of spain i'm getting video of
of of the queen of the netherlands at
the video okay
and then they're saying it doesn't exist
you know you know the hard part is
there's the assumption the collapse is
on purpose that all the problems are
seeing on purpose and then the
assumption that joe biden is just a
crackpot who's fumbling and destroying
everything and they do that on purpose
so you think he's doing it all while
you're losing your freedom losing your
borders globalism coming into the nation
so let's think about the ramifications
of what's been happening over the past
couple of years people working remote
good thing or bad thing
good generally i think decentralization
yes they just shouldn't have the right
to make us do it
i agree authoritarianism is bad and that
we that we're supposed to have uh you
know they want to teach us that we don't
have the right to mobility but i agree a
mix of it's good but see they get a lot
of people on board with their martial
law saying hey don't you agree with
telecommunicating telecommunicating well
so this is one of the reasons this is
good is it's going to make sure that
parents are with their kids now more
kids are going to be
actually being taught by homeschooling
but not just that if the kids are going
to be
watching their parents studies show if
you're highly educated or highly
informed and active i mean like you you
have a confident crew here and people
that that'll make you better that
doesn't make the average person better
that it's breaking down production's
going way down they that's what they're
driving people back into the buildings
because you have that synergy of groups
of people yeah we need to go away from
working hourly now and work towards cut
project completion so it doesn't matter
how long you take you're working from
home take your time and get it done that
only works and that'll only work in
certain certain circumstances though
there are certain things project
completion like that doesn't work for
for uh you know every circumstance so
most people can't do it i mean most
people aren't top three or four
podcasters like you are
or you know successful musicians i mean
it's i'm sorry what i'm saying is
people uh uh
dispersing off of cities good people
being around their kids good people
learning personal responsibility good
people experiencing hardship can suck
but good necessary yeah so now we're
seeing a lot of things that are
bad because of the authoritarianism
and i think you know if we could be
pessimistic about it we can obviously
resist the authoritarianism make sure
they don't
do anything that's like i mean they're
doing a lot of things that are
destructive and i mean what i mean by
that i mean just like various special
interests and corporations that are
buying up properties that are hurting
the little guy there's a there's a big
challenge in this because you know one
of the things that we were talking about
alex before the show is
something called windshield phenomenon
yes that's uh because you tell it better
than i don't want you to repeat that
we've talked about before but it's
basically you go driving you get less
bugs on your windshield
and so it's really interesting to hear
you talk about it because you sound like
you're concerned about overpopulation
and climate change when i ask you about
the stuff not necessarily like i am
absolutely concerned about the
environment and conservation and i've
drive all over texas and i remember 20
years ago
back when i was a child whether it was
in the fall whether it was in the spring
of the summer your car would be caked
with bugs
and now i drive out to our east texas
property where i go quite often and i
mean i'll drive in the springtime when
they see the most bugs they're all
hatching and there's like
two bugs on my windshield and it used to
be i used to have to pull over at gas
stations twice and clean the dead bugs
off there used to be bees everywhere
so definitely we're killing the planet
but the very globalists that are telling
us to give them control over our lives
are the ones that are saying oh we're
just going to transcend immersive
machines we'll make a thousand planets
we're going to rewrite the entire earth
they're on a power trip they're going to
become gods ray kurzweil talks about all
of them now i don't believe in god's yet
i'm going to become one and so
they're the very ones that are handing
out all the weapons systems and the ones
that are you know doing all these things
trying to keep people dumbed down and
poor to control us and then they tell us
oh give up your life force give up your
own life because it'll save the earth
you're going to live in austerity you're
not essential you live in a 200 square
foot coffin apartment while they live in
giant palatial mansions on the ocean
telling you the sea level is going to
rise and you're going to die when really
that's not what's going on what's going
on is they're saying oh you're bad for
the earth so you shouldn't have a life
force you need to just crawl in a hole
and die so we can inherit the earth we
need to admit the earth's in trouble has
problems come together innovate with
real technologies but they don't they
call those disruptive technologies all
the real stuff they've got they've been
suppressing that's all of their
conversations i think that humanity for
our inception for a long time has been
super racistly annihilating other life
on earth like the neander all these nato
i imagine humans wiped out the the homo
florences the neanderthals we wipe out
all these animals we're in this mass
extinction because for safety we need we
don't want to die to some savior that's
like people on a ranch it's like they
just when my dad was a child they killed
the last wolf in the county and they
would like get all the permission to go
over over 20 people's property they'd be
hunt all night in the freezing cold and
finally spotlight it and kill it my dad
said he felt sorry for it because they
just they had an instinct we had to kill
every environment
we gotta get everything since since
we've invented radio and tv and been
able to watch ourselves and learn about
what we are what i am we've gained this
new level of consciousness where it
seems like people really care about our
species and the earth in a new way i
completely disagree
i really think that
just because we've been able to just
because we've had technological advances
i don't think human beings are
any in any way significantly different
than they were
a thousand years ago evolutionarily
there has been
nothing that has
forced human beings to change we as soon
as we
as soon as we attain the ability to
affect our
circumstances our surrounding as soon as
we became able to clothe ourselves feed
ourselves just got weaker yeah well i'm
not maybe that that's arguable but their
evolution doesn't work without some kind
of outside force right like so humans
haven't evolved because there hasn't
been a reason for us to evolve since
we've been able to
to you know since our thumbs and our
brains allowed us to create the world
around us well do you call it evolve or
devolve because we've definitely changed
what about just valve
i'm thinking so like the way that
evolution works or at least my you know
layman understanding is it takes an
outside uh
pressure and usually happens in big
jumps because there's a big pressure
sure but it's still it takes an outside
pressure to make
make you know a species or or an
organism evolve as soon as human beings
became able to
create things uh you know whether it be
i'm thinking before the industrial
evolution probably as soon as we the key
is we change our environment we exactly
we reform we control our environment as
opposed to having to adapt to our
environment so i'm not i really don't
think that people are are significantly
different now um than they were and
that's what the globalists are doing is
they are using our our
ability to work with tools and change
our environment for us to trick us into
an environment that will extinct this
because they believe they're making this
new homo sapien that's going to merge
the machines and transcend that's their
transfumous religion and and they have a
real religion that that they're gonna
use us like rocket boosters on the space
shuttle to get into orbit so then we're
gonna follow along so you talk about
well you're talking about religion and
there's that's that's one of the things
that i think is
not different people people tend to say
and and i'm referencing what ian was
talking about humans have evolved to
this different space or to indeed we've
we've become aware and et cetera et
cetera and i don't think that we have
and i think that that religion and the
way that people treat the state nowadays
is evidence of that so
religion is religion is ubiquitous with
human beings right every every society
throughout all of human history has had
some form of religion so it's not just
that a society came up with it it's that
religion goes hand in hand with human
beings even you know societies that are
are separated by you know
different times different areas and
stuff different places on the planet
that never had any kind of interaction
they all had religion and nowadays
people have
almost have basically assumed that the
state is their religion as you know when
nietzsche said
god is dead that was you know that
wasn't some triumphant thing that he was
talking about it was like he didn't know
what what human beings were going to the
next thing was hitler well he predicted
he predicted communism and he predicted
nazism and and
the
the way that people treat the government
and and especially now the you see it i
think manifest with with the whole covid
let me take that full circle i got i
wanted to address what you were saying
about um
evolution of humans
and then becoming robots and all that
stuff you know i i got to say look when
i grew when i was growing up i remember
watching star trek the next generation
and as as a you know a young man growing
up in the united states me and all my
friends seeing the show always looked up
and wanted to be the borg right that's
the show's about how the borg is great
and you want to be a minus automaton
with the borg queen who controls you and
you have no say-so no i don't agree with
that oh really
you don't want to be the board let me
say both these guys are right
it's a complex system they use sociology
and they use anthropology and behavioral
psychology to to figure out religions we
believe in so we'll follow their system
but the globalist religion is scientific
elites using us as guinea pigs to try to
transcend to the next level and that is
the transhumanist 2.0 eugenics movement
and so
it's all it's all well
we should we should i'm gonna how about
for the member segment we let you just
give us the powerpoint presentation of
all of that and break down i'll try it
tonight it's a lot of points but the
thing is a lot of people do hit that
point of caring about communal and
humans and projecting it on the earth
and and transcending all of that and not
being selfish and so they manipulate
good people and and i get motivated too
saying let us have control we'll save
the earth let's not be selfish don't you
understand and then you give over your
will to them believing you're part of a
group with this new religion to be
depopulating or to be cutting back what
we're doing to save the earth for the
greater good
but if you go back to actually the most
ancient religions the pagan religions
before judaism and christianity and you
see abraham there when you know god says
sacrifice your son and then he goes
that's not needed anymore that's a
lesson to stop human sacrifice for the
jews you know by god
and so however you see that that goes
back to the environmentalist the pagans
were always killing children and women
and men and the druids would sometimes
demand the king's son or the king if
there was no rain and no crops they
would sometimes say we've got five years
of no food the gods want the king to be
killed now and so it was all this mumbo
jumbo oh the sun didn't come back a
goblin ate it or a snake ate it we've
got to have a bunch of
a bunch of sacrifices so that that you
know so the snake spits the sun of the
moon back up and so that's what was
going on there so it's full circle
the u.n talks about 1960s documents that
i've covered on air we're going to
recreate paganism and recreate human
sacrifice and make them love
depopulation so that it'll be and that
paganism was the way to go so see it all
just comes back to full circle i i you
know part of me wants to believe we live
in this fantasy world that's much like
full metal alchemist or something i just
don't i just don't see it i think
i think it's much more routine and
boring than people realize well that's
because of western civilization decided
to up production and make life better
and empower everybody compared to other
systems it's not perfect but it's the
best and the globalists look at that and
say this make everybody fat dumb and
spoiled let's give them artificial wars
let's give them artificial poisons and
let's let's let let's be the wolf that
calls the you know the overpopulation of
deer let's come in and give them
survival the fittest social darwinism
that is the globalist religion is social
darwinism and artificial money that
bothers me that they went fiat with the
money nixon took us off the gold
standard which gives them all the power
and the federal reserve yeah this it
gave it gave this massive amount of
power to this upper structure to be able
to create infinite amounts of money at
will and now they can buy everybody off
it's not about creating infinite money
it's it's about being being able to
extract resources and labor from people
with them in agreement to it to to fake
money to basically basically if when you
you get nothing
well no no no no no they're giving you
nothing but invisible tax the the the
the printing and borrowing of money
causing inflation you sitting there
looking at your bank like my number is
fine but the milk keeps going more and
more expensive because they can use and
they get the first use of the money they
get to buy companies and patents and
land and ideas and people and then you
get the inflation later i'm fully
convinced that there's no running away
and there's no charging directly at it
but we have to pass through it with this
decentralized internet well i just hope
the globalists know their plan's not
going to work they need to back off this
they're just going to cause giant wars
of everybody killing each other
in pakistan and india and it's just
that what you just said they wanted what
people just killing each other yeah but
that the weapon systems are too
dangerous that's why they want to
depopulate everybody right now
before they have that big war because
they know they'll still be such large
populations you know you know what's
really crazy
we see these movies where you have these
massive battlefields of like tens of
thousands of people we have millions of
people living in cities
when you look back at these stories in
history like the revolution and you hear
about what happened this battle on the
you know this this this great battle
that happened on the hill and we imagine
like just waves of thousands of soldiers
charging at each other like in the
movies and there's probably like 100
people
because there was there were
substantially less people back then the
united states had two million people at
the time of the revolution two million
yeah so when there were battles going on
it wasn't like grand armies of fifty
thousand marching towards each other
there's a couple hundred uh and i wanna
point out it's not that they want war i
don't think they want people to kill
each other i think they want less
reproduction i think that's the great
reset is about less they want us to
phase out and you're saying if it's
mishandled it could cause global
catastrophe it sounds like they want
people
so you know you know what i always
wondered you know have you followed the
van life youtube stuff yes so this was
really fascinating there was this one
woman who i guess she quit youtube but
she gained like a million subscribers in
one day off one van life video
and everyone started asking whoa whoa
she did one video and she gets all i
think she did one she did two videos she
did one video and she's got a bunch of
views second video kaboom million
subscribers it's like the fastest growth
anyone's ever seen cause people want
freedom no because youtube said there's
a glitch in the algorithm that's strange
why was the algorithm promoting van life
and so you have to wonder about youtube
propping up videos that tell young
people to sell off all your possessions
and go live in a van they will get you a
debt i i i totally agree i'm in favor of
that idea that's what i do no no it's
freedom it makes sense but they want
micro houses micro apartments and van
life sounds great they want you to get
deeper into debt they don't want you to
basically have
any type of future and so again they
manipulate that listen i vans suck okay
i spent enough time in a van
professional
yeah i mean
when we were getting started vans vans
suck yeah with multiple people i got a
nice fan well you're yeah your van
it's not for one person all the left
wages on fossil fuels how many hours you
get in a van phil no no but
or at least hundreds is hundreds so i
think about it this way and uh um having
come from more humble means i suppose
probably i love the idea of a tiny house
with my own little fishing hole and
humble living they're not gonna have
that yeah they're not gonna i mean
they're they're telling them just gonna
live by the river and and and you know
and statistically you'll end up being
homeless next
you know what i think there's a large
portion of people who can't support
themselves
and so what do we do
you know no that's it and so they say
don't just be homeless you live in a van
let's let's let's do some quick math
when they do promote when when the great
reset when the davos people say you will
owe nothing and you will be happy that's
literally a quote from the world
economic forum they said that about the
year 2030 or whatever what what will
life be like you will so let's think
about something real quick can the
average person who owns nothing survive
the answer is no
well they're going to make you
sign on to the universal income and then
dictate you'll be sterilized that's
admitted
well that sounds like fallout the
original game i don't know i don't know
about all that stuff but the problem is
alex you say you know i wonder if what
you're pulling off as a secret as a
trojan horse like you've you've found
these stores that sound crazy but are
easily provable right so you're like
cloned beef and we're like no we look it
up and it turns out to be i never played
fallout no i mean but then you think
it's good but then you but then you say
one thing that we can't check and we're
alive i'll tell you right now where you
can pull it up um
type in united nations
u.n developing uh anti-fertility vaccine
or or uh you know proposals for
universal basic income
uh and uh sterilization all right and
they're proposing it and they're saying
that we'll go we'll go nuts in the in
the timcast.com show would you do
something i want to keep going and i
want this guy to talk he's awesome can i
go to the bathroom yeah we're going to
do a super chat you guys are wondering
i'm going to take a piss do it we're
going to read super chats
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah you can second
door on the wall
yeah we'll we'll read super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
many people already have and make sure
you go to timcast.com because
if you thought this was crazy we
actually
have alex jones unleashed
we were like we need someone to help
like you know come in and you know and
phil's just laughing and i'm just
pouring gas on the fire go
go
oh man um so i'm not going to read every
single super chat that said alex jones
was right there are a lot of them
um just a stee says where's michael
malus and g edward griffin at you guys
are killing it keep up the good work i
mean that sounds fun do we have plans
for those two toward the end of october
i wanted to get uh dave smith in here
with uh with g edward i want to see
those two together the libertarians at
it yeah that'd be really cool michael
mouse works with everybody all right
he's great he's the best yes he is
powder pz says no seriously no joke i'm
trapped how do i escape california oh
i mean you just leave
what kind of trap as much one step at a
time how about that yeah i mean i
understand that like slowly and then all
at once it's a lot easier said than done
but like
if you're if you really want to get out
of there i mean whatever you're doing in
california you could probably do
somewhere else
and you'll it's probably cheaper to live
somewhere else so i think it's a good
idea to download a survival guide i
downloaded two
and you can download the entire contents
of wikipedia yeah you can whoa could you
imagine if you're the entire contents of
wikipedia like went back in time to the
1600s you know that's smart with the way
the world's working the next big thing
davos group is talking about doing is
how the terrorists are going to launch a
big power outage
which will let them have the great reset
even bigger everybody
in the bathroom guys this is exactly
these are long lines and i think because
you're like how do we get out of this
you've got to revolve the currency from
money to electricity before his acid
this hit the seat he's like davos is out
okay you guys are all right okay you
know here's where we go i'm trying to
warn people
we got a question for you
crandall logan says mr jones i don't
have anything on human animal hybrids
but have you heard anything about the
animal hybrids spider goats at utah
state university they are goats that
produce spider silk in their milk to be
removed in larger amounts for body armor
yes i covered that 28 years ago wow and
people didn't believe me because i uh
27 years ago i had the director at an
army base for the private research lab i
was proud of it i saw some research
magazine that nobody knew about and i
got him on he got in trouble with the
army after it but yeah that was in
upstate new york they were they had like
over a thousand of these goats that
their milk they look like regular goats
it's just that they have the spider
gene in their uh milk producing glands
in in their mammary glands that puts out
this protein they can then use for body
armor some and like in like really
strong ropes and stuff like that it was
a and so now they've upped the larger
production they have cows for at least
20 years in china that produce human
milk what other that are part yeah the
big thing is see
you have animal rights movements you
also have human rights movements so they
make humanoids that are only like one
percent animal but now it's a gray zone
that has no rights
wait humanoids that are one percent
animal
yeah so it's really a huge other way
around or what no i know they do the
pigs they're doing pigs where they're
trying to grow human organs and pigs for
transplant yes but but they also grow
the humanoids they just don't roll that
out and advertise that but it's in all
the research papers it's a lot of
research papers
i mean i was reading about human animal
hybrids 25 years ago
uh in in in
type this in human animals we've got to
do super chats well human they ask human
animal hybrids are chest dating on u.s
farms that's mit came out like three
years ago chest stating cage
dating just just dating us
all right all right all right i i we we
will go through all of this stuff
there's one thing i want to say though
whenever you're ready just about in
general we will i want to make it i mean
that's
the people review.com the people who are
uh uh is it news guard certified i don't
know the people who are super chatting i
wanna make sure that we get the news
guard is is uh microsoft it has to be
authorized by bill gates that's right
does newsguard authorize that bill gates
things around jeffrey epstein lied about
it
i got fact checked for saying that bill
that bill clinton flew on the plane they
called it false that's on the log
i know but it's like and so when i
argued with the fact checker he was like
well it sounded the way you said it was
different so i called it false and i'm
like but it's true
well again let's let's read this who
checks the fact checkers yeah great
question well we we have filed for a
non-profit fact-checking organization to
quite literally factor the fact checkers
i i will trust your fact-checking yeah i
mean we'll do our best we're not going
to trust no it's going to be it's going
to be like an encyclopedia where we show
the article we we will like actually
show what we're questioning
and we're going to create a list of
these different news organizations a
score 0 out of 100. so we're going to
randomly sample 100 articles from like
the past month or three months or
however long and then we're going to go
through them looking for violations of
standard journalistic ethics give them a
strike if they do and then it'll be like
67 out of 100 articles reviewed were
considered you know good you know
ethical journalism wow and then we'll
show the list of the unethical
journalism a lot of it's going to be
opinion a lot of it's going to be just
like this is an opinion piece this is an
opinion piece and if it's an opinion
piece not labeled as opinion you get a
strike if it's factually incorrect you
get a strike if you try to harm people
you get a strike so we're gonna be doing
that but let's read some more
joshua farah says defund afge
federal employee union dues are not
mandatory for representation i don't see
why any member would give them a dime
after this federal unions are notorious
for defending the worst employees
imaginable and yet some of the best
employees might be lost due to this
mandate
i mean i have something to say about
that surprisingly
you have these unions that have sold all
these jobs out and now you have these
unions saying yeah let's forcibly
inoculate federal employees but then
congress and their staff are going to be
exempt it just it's out of control i
mean how do they exempt themselves from
vaccine mandates that's total
discrimination and when we think about
the race or something or how what color
we are that that that's all the
distraction i found when we're all
having our basic rights screwed over
mount romer says in the beginning of
this conversation alex jones dropped
some serious red pill history bombs on
you fact check it all right yeah the
illuminati french revolution stuff is
key did you look it up i was uh i
started too yeah i was reading a little
bit about it all right let's see
where was i at
i thought i had something pulled up but
i guess i got uh
jumped yeah i must have jumped youtube
hey
a lot of people are just saying they
like you alex and that you're right
there's a lot of people saying that
you're right
sunny james says did werner von braun
wrote project mars
doctor verner von braun wrote project
mars a technical tale is that sonny
james uh jesse james's daughter
i don't know i don't know if it is hi
sonny he's friends with my daughter oh
okay really nice lady
guess the name of the fictional mars
ruler
that's elon it is but but let's let's
talk about that
what was the question about vernon von
braun
uh no no it wasn't there was she was
saying he did write
elon musk's father
wrote a noverner von braun wrote a book
about the elon's that rule and the
dictator being named elon on mars
and then uh elon musk's father named
milan so it's a big question
elon musk wants to go to mars
yeah he's gonna be the king of mars
l uh uh
five five i don't know sorry i can't
pronounce your name the crazy stuff alex
jones is right about makes me
worried there is actually
interdimensional child abusing vampires
i just thought regular democrats were
bad
no i mean the globe a lot of cultures
believe that you hurt children and
energy is released and they can feed off
that energy i'm telling you what these
some of these people believe and i'm
telling you what's at archaeological
sites around the earth so a lot of
humans because i have no desire to cut
children's hearts out i don't know why
this keeps happening i would i would
advise checking your ego because when
that power flows through you uh don't
twist it
you know a lot of people uh boss boss
troll says the project veritas kova
video drop you should watch it before
the corporate overlords take it down i
just want to say that i'm glad to know
that alex doesn't want to cut children's
hearts out
as most people should agree they don't
want to do that you know i talked to
veritas or chief like last week they
said this is going to be so huge the
corporate whistleblower and that they
think this is the thing that may get
them banned so
once we know what's going on in
overdrive we can talk about yeah so what
we'll do is once we wrap up here i think
for the members then we'll just play it
and we'll all watch it in real time and
react to it
so uh
ryonan taka says tim is already
triggered that alex wasn't wrong
you know that's the challenge because
some of it's like that sounds wrong i
look it up and it's right but that's not
true that's not true joe rogan did the
fact checking and he figured i'd be
right about most stuff and you know that
too so it's fun tim likes me tim tim is
not insecure or he wouldn't have such an
obnoxious person on oh yeah i i i we had
zubi on the show and he said vitamin and
i said you pronounce vitamin wrong it
was no i didn't and i was like yeah it's
vital man or only no it's not and i was
like yeah it is and he's like look it up
and i was wrong and i was like god you
got me that's from like i don't care no
but i mean
it would have you'd have been right
though yeah but you're not like it's fun
to fact check me and see if the crazy
stuff's true yeah lightning believe me i
make mistakes sometimes especially as
i've gotten older oh man i'll like mix
like two different things together i
have my memory and i'll get it wrong
yeah everyone that listened to the show
should fact check everything yes
every time
and and that's the thing is people are
allowed to say what i mean if i want to
say that i've been to mars with elon
musk as a joke i should be able to say
it or if i want to i mean then i'll be
known as a discredited person people
have their right to free speech that's
one thing bill maher said about me he
said everybody gets free speech
including alex jones that's the way it
is they said oh how dare him because he
understands his bread and butter is free
speech and i don't think he should be
censored either phil said whatever he
wants well he doesn't say go kill these
people no that's not speech that's
that's that's calling for a violent
action no one should be you should there
shouldn't i mean the the reasons to not
censor people are are
i mean they should be obvious you want
to be able to
select like you want to be able to tell
who the bad people are you want people
to feel comfortable to say what they
believe so you can be like i don't want
to be around that guy he sucks yes
brayden t says shu went on tower gang
which is a libertarianish posting pod
she's not afraid of cc cancer culture
it's about being pushed by serious ideas
that scare her in my opinion oh i don't
know i'm not familiar with tower game
i'm familiar with tower gang
they're they're just libertarian like
[ __ ] lords oh pardon my friend now
whatever
uh tget says i desperately want a
philabonte screaming yes ringtone name
your price yeah click the ft's let's see
the next world yes there are there are
nfts all that remains nft's coming oh
cool solid all the remains could we nft
episodes of the show or something you
know i bet we could but like what does
that mean you get a digital you own the
original digital copy yeah no they
wouldn't on the original digital copy we
would but they would own the nft version
of the yeah the original nft that's the
weird thing about it
but what happened to the so-called left
is they got taken over by the
corporations they want to be on the
winning team
i mean
i mean how is being anti-free speech oh
it's just our platform and then now
senator rand paul
talks about natural immunity of being
better and so his video in the senate
gets taken down i mean that's dangerous
folks and i can't believe congress has
put up with us everybody talks about how
great rand paul is i think he's doing
the bare minimum he gets like a a minus
uh everybody else is getting like an f
including the republicans because the
truth is they're all getting paid off
with the same people it's really really
out of control
i'm trying to find some good questions
it's hard
because a lot of people are just saying
alex jones is right
it's like we're trying to convince the
population to get on our side or oh i'm
trying to get them to get on my side
because
yeah people are getting twisted but
it's like a dance i don't want to dance
i want to just tell them the answer but
they want to see me dance because they
want to enjoy it and then they'll
believe me i'll tell you the answer bill
joy in 1999 co-founder owner of some
micro says it's worth four billion time
four billion dollars at the time
probably worth more of that today he
wrote a big article called why the
future doesn't need us for wired
magazine
and he endorsed theodore kazinski
unibomber it was part of the cia mk
ultra mind control program that's
another issue that was declassified and
he said i went to a conference with
other 200 or so other billionaires and
tech owners and we had a vote after
three days and we decided
that
that we just don't want to keep people
around in mass anymore we're not just
going to let them play video games and
you know do whatever really it's not
good for the earth and human life when
we're not stressed enough is not worth
anything so the group consensus was we
need to get rid of the majority of
people and so we can all sit around
academically and go yeah there are a lot
of dumb lazy people but you know
in that act of playing god it's it's
it's really really evil you can go read
why the future doesn't need is bill joy
and see that for yourself
mystic fox says tim if you will put all
the proof of alex's claims on your site
i will subscribe to your website okay i
will hire an alex jones reporter
who will just research i like that it'd
be me
you can hire me we're going to hire an
independent i want to find somebody who
recently got laid off from like vice or
something
and then make them do nothing but watch
alex jones videos
yeah there's probably people that are
already memorized and i would love to
see my score i want to get it up i want
to like you know get my score up higher
no but we can uh i think actually uh
it would be really cool to bring on
somebody to investigate and break down
the conspiracy theories on the web and
like do a fact check of them show show
the source of the conspiracies the ideas
the proof the claims because i feel like
you when you go to the mainstream media
often they use like semantic tricks
so it'll be like did bill clinton fly on
the plane with jeffrey epstein
ice cream false they didn't get ice
cream they flew to you know whatever
island that's exactly what they do or
they do stuff i mean there's so many
examples of it but they'll say you know
alex because they'll use me because i'm
seeing his quote not being credible by
they think the mainstream still so they
didn't fact check the senate report they
didn't fact check the wall street
journal that said they go is it true
that biden is now going to watch
everybody's bank account for any six
hundred dollars or more in every
transaction above that
no it's not true and then way down at
the bottom it's not been implemented yet
it's just a proposal by him
and it's like you know crazy the actual
thing is if you have 600 or more in your
account they're going to track every
transaction yeah i mean all i was doing
was like reading the wall street journal
and i went and looked at the proposal it
was true i didn't just believe them and
then i'm like yeah look at this idiot he
wants to do this that turns it he said
biden's currently doing it well i mean
it's like he's trying to do it i mean it
doesn't even matter but that's what they
do they
here's the deal
i'm not consciously trying to let
anybody about anything and i'm not some
super evil right wing dude the left got
mad at me because they think i got trump
elected
and quite frankly i don't think that's
the case i'm not backing away from trump
i was really upset with trump pushing
this vaccine i knew they'd try to make
it mandatory at least he isn't for being
mandatory but he wants to believe he did
this big heroic thing and he's up there
saying this is totally effective i love
it it's really wonderful well according
to the israeli studies it's not as
effective as 100 percent but we're not
allowed to say that on youtube in fact
it's totally effective you'll live
forever no no no we can we we'll just
we'll put it simply as
fauci has been having discussions with
biden's about the requirements of
booster shots due to reduced efficacy
over time
but we should be able to say israel has
done the most studies it was a big
government study one of the biggest ever
conducted and they're saying that i mean
you can pull up the article oh yeah you
know we we we've talked about israel's
data it's horrible i was once 39 years
old
and and then
speaking everybody everybody speaks in
code online now you think about it we're
in the soviet union
i mean it's like you know i think
psychic energy is i mean i think psychic
it's real
oh there's definitely the hundreds of
monkey syndrome you know about that
yeah oh yeah they were washing uh uh
yams it wasn't coconuts it was yams
monkeys on an island and then
eventually like somewhere like a hundred
monkeys started washing their yams like
one of the monkeys and then all of a
sudden around the world these other
monkeys on other islands started washing
their yams
yeah well they even had islands it was
in the south pacific like 30 miles away
and
and the anthropologists and people were
watching it and and then they're sitting
there looking at this
animal behaviorist like uh desmond
morris types and then all of a sudden as
soon as that a group calling did it like
broadcast it they were doing it no no
they didn't broadcast anything you guys
didn't understand it was it was it was a
patch
updated yeah they updated they updated
the 1.7 the simulation updated to
include you know monkeyswashy m's
some some developer came in he was like
i don't know over the weekend i just
made a thing it's a cool feature where
they'll wash ems and they're like well
that's how the globalists see it as they
see in the hegelian dialectic you have
your libertarians your right wingers you
know this group that group gay straight
black white old young and all of it are
just levers and movements that they
didn't start or even control but now
through dumbing people down and by all
the propaganda they just see all those
movements that can play off against each
other and this is actually a big
simulation they're trying to make with
the ai and the computers you know about
the founding of the internet right in in
nineteen
the precursor of darpa because it was
arpa uh this big psychiatrist super
brain like a 200 iq i forget his name
you look it up he created the
intergalactic communication system
that's what it was called and he said
we'll have big computer terminals we'll
be able to miniaturize them down to
handheld and then we will use that with
big screens everywhere that we'll have
by then he was saying by the year like
2020 he wanted to do it and then and
then they would be able as behavioral
psychologists to control all of us with
our handheld computers that were
watching us and tracking us and when
they make us daily to be able to have
our job or leave have to go download it
into the main computers because he was
thinking something different than
couldn't see that far in the future so
darpa came along and created the whole
system for it for all of this to create
a hive mind ai
interface that they want and when google
got set up in
1998 with the cia inquitel funding they
actually admitted that was their plan of
the human neural interface with this
computer system to teach it how to be
uh through machine learning and
interface with humans that's kind of
i'll trade some more super chances
intergalactic computer network that's
jcr lick lighter the first director of
processing techniques office at the
pentagon's arpa oh
let's see iman says i haven't seen tim
this frustrated in a long time lmao alex
jones definitely needs to be on more
often glad i got my tim cast membership
as i feel a youtube band is coming soon
us basket of deplorables need to stick
together hey tim is welcome on my show
and so is everybody else we got to
figure out this uh this texas trip
because we have the trailer to do this
guy's come on the show and he'll beat me
up on him for talking too much ah you
guys are both texas we've got we've got
definitely going here we got a uh
trailer actually you have been i was on
with when my uh when milo yiannopoulos
was i remember that's right that's right
and i'll let you talk a little more then
yes
but it's okay though you're being nice
talk right now well i mean you know i
don't want to be rude uh first of all
and second of all i thoroughly enjoy the
uh the the tales that you spend
especially when when we go ahead and
search and find the kernel of truth
well about the intergalactic
communication system that wasn't a
colonel no no i get i get it i'm i'm not
i guess i've read like 500 pages from
arpa yeah they're all so wild the matrix
is an actual pentagon plan did you know
this no uh the carnegie endowment which
runs the cia today always did set it up
now the former director runs it because
they're just fully taken over they said
to end war they wanted proposals and in
the 70s one that they looked at in 79
that was 77 was it birth to put us in
tanks where our own heat powers it
they'll have robots with these farms
that grow the food and all that it was
it was more limited just a quick
proposal matrix expands on it and that
will end all wars will be in a virtual
reality so there's peace what if we're
in the virtual reality now well that was
the pentagon plan and and then they
declassified it in 2000 and then they
asked for it to be reclassified
what if we're in the matrix what if the
simulation isn't for fun what if the
simulation is the matrix and all the
monkeys watching yams was because they
updated it was it was a glitch
it's possible as things are are uh
fractal but i think that we really got
to take it seriously like they're trying
to put humanity in a matrix right now
yeah
that's why working at home is bad which
it's good if it's free
that they can surveil everything you're
doing online and now you notice all the
big companies from berkshire hathaway to
microsoft to apple apple employees
finally got it last month and wrote a
letter and the media focused on them
saying we're being sexually harassed or
being mean to us that was a small part
which is important that shouldn't have
happened but the main thrust was they
make us be on the icloud and they see
everything we do and they talk about it
and our bosses all have access to us in
a class system we're against this you
know what the dangerous thing is the
word they there's so many definitions of
what it means well it's the new super
technocracy class and so once you're at
home on a computer they all make you go
on and now they're quote activating the
microphone activating the camera same
thing happened to richard snowden in the
cia where the guy's watching him banging
his wife and later tells edward
everstone yeah it says names oh they did
that let's read something let's see i
made a mistake i want to say richard
snowden yeah everybody on that mistake
there you go mr obvious says here's
double for alex jones in my opinion they
aren't refugees they're economic
migrants america has around 40 million
people below the poverty line we need to
take care of ourselves we need borders
tell alex jones i love him no i totally
agree that that i mean
most these haitians have been in south
america and colombia and other areas
since the earthquake for four or five
years and knew it obviously and they
were in there complaining in the news in
the videos in france translated they
don't give us enough free stuff in
colombia
and so now we're here for the free stuff
and imagine
they're here with cell phones they're
here with money to buy toppaco and you
know
enchiladas and bring them over this this
is the middle class of haiti that left
there i don't blame them and then went
to south america and that's collapsing
on the lockdown so they said the
lockdown is making a starve we have to
come here so again we have a very
important question for you alex a says
why is dragon ball z the greatest anime
and naruto is the second and lastly why
is black black clover and my hero
academia tied for third we want the
truth damn it
i have never really watched dragon ball
z until they take that thing where i go
super saiyan or something
like that and there's a little and your
hair goes yeah
so that's a little bit of fun there yeah
beautiful all right
all right let's see uh
i swore i was going to come here and be
called but you were yeah that's all good
you're an animal this is actually dialed
back in the literal sense of life
i bet i speak for the rest of the
interview with a british accent oh god
you're scared you're like a zen master
dude
all right gym master
it's very good to be here with you tim
oh my gosh incredible little shells
shell some intellectual ideas with you
that's very good i must stay this
facility is quite
manchester it's
grandiosity have you ever taken
psychedelics and like just meditated had
like just
transformative experiences
yes when i was very young we should do
that let's do that again let's get young
get young let's lay out on the golf
course and take five hits of acid three
hits of peyote well let's go let's micro
go let's start
let's let's go real slow
you said you want to have a giant
transformative event i'm interested in
ayahuasca i think i think it would be
amazing for society to have a high
profile ayahuasca journey with the dieta
leading up to it the 10-day fast and it
could be incredible
and you're coming i'll waste it could be
scary mm-hmm
tim pool you wanna take ayahuasca with
me no i wouldn't do it
no i'm not i'm not into that stuff i
like hearing about i like the research
but i wouldn't would you sit with me
well sit with us while we're doing it
yeah i'd film it but a lot of it you're
crapping and
that's the most odd but a lot of that's
because
it wasn't
filming if you fast for 10 days you
don't want people to watch what happens
it's all that [ __ ] in your system it's
getting rid of
that means it's working well let me tell
you after 10 days you're not eating i
don't know what i'd be like yeah you get
you get vegetables with no salt that's
basically it sauteed vegetables and no
salt
no sugar no bread nothing
i like cucumbers
yeah and then i think the ayahuasca
treats you well have you done ayahuasca
no i sipped on it when i was in south
america i could feel the dnc rush coming
on but i didn't i haven't taken those
like smoking it didn't take a third hit
no yeah i was just it tasted like grass
it was really bitter like grass like
heating grass
joe danker says if alex jones didn't
exist we'd have to invent him
guys i'm just telling you crazy factoids
out of history here
i just love
you know when i interviewed you today
you were bringing up the fact that they
tried to cancel me and everybody else
and all it's doing is forcing people to
build their own thing i think that's a
very american thing tim mm-hmm dude
you're gonna be starting out the fed of
verse alex uh brought me into the woods
and now i got allergies and it's it's
slaying me
i it's your new green room it's a very
nice woods you've got here yeah pretty
uh pretty beautiful woods paw paw
everywhere papa yeah little papas you
know i didn't think we had that many and
then you walk into the woods and they
hit you in the head they fall down
they're crazy i ain't a paw paw the
first time here good right it's like a
mango avocado banana all mashed into it
i was like a little monkey and i ate out
of my security guy's hand
[Laughter]
i love it i love this mental image
is it that true
so there's
i am going through the super chats
trying to find good questions the
challenge is there's uh a lot of them
are just like hey alex phil big fans we
love you love the show and so i don't
want to not read everyone's but no i
want to read it all i want to be here
all night
well no i mean you do have me not
drinking this is what alex jones is not
drinking they're they're loving it
there's too many
and uh
oh well here's one that's very very
basic under 100 calories says have you
guys thought of making an app
and for alex have you heard of the
podcast zed cast they're big big fans we
are working on an app have you heard of
zed cast
i have seen a lot of stuff i forget the
names but
it does ring a bell
scott kundal says the most powerful
weapon in 1869 was a crude crud machine
gun 76 years later the a-bomb
76 years later is now do you feel the a
bomb is still
it or propaganda advancing in that same
75 years straight well yeah uh h.g wells
wrote
long before we went into the 20th
century it was like 18
18. yeah yeah
they wrote about atomic weapons because
they can already theoretically talk
about it max planck and the german
physicist had already by 1898 come up
with the theoretical physics and quantum
mechanics for atomic bombs then they
were able to purify it and get it and
then you know the germans almost got it
with their light water uh
reactors and then of course we had our
systems here with the whole manhattan
project and so the atomic bomb is 1898
technology the hydrogen bomb is you know
theoretically uh was 1920s technology
but deployed in the 50s and so the air
force let it leak in this in the
several papers they put out about 10
years ago
that they've actually harnessed and
developed antimatter bombs uh but but
they've never they've only theoretically
tested them and they think that they
probably destroy the whole solar system
i don't know
so i was reading about that and they
said the problem is producing antimatter
is ridiculously expensive and has to be
stored in magnetic rings because once it
comes into contact with standard
explosives yeah it's a general 100
percent energy release
but um
i want to ask you do you know how much
stronger modern nuclear weapons and i
say modern i mean like the 90s do you
know how much stronger they are than the
than the bombs we dropped on about 5 000
times
so uh if we're talking about a multiple
independently [ __ ] uh talk about an
icbm merv technology coming back into
the injury because not only does it
carry eight to twelve warheads but
they're also substantially more powerful
each absolutely so one icb icbm could
pepper the entire eastern seaboard yeah
like fat boy uh or
little boy and fat man i mean those were
weren't even megatons i mean they were
they're really small yep so modern
weapons people don't realize they look
at they look at history and they're like
oh the nuclear weapons like you have no
idea how powerful the modern weapons are
now you know by the time we drop those
on them in 1945 out of the nola gay and
the rest of it
they already had had
2 000 plane sorties going in on they
waited till the day when they were like
50 mile an hour winds so it basically
burned down half of japan probably
killed 5 million people in one day they
were already trying to surrender then so
see using primitive technology of just
fire bombs was actually better than
atomic bombs at that time they just
dropped those on them to scare the
russians now here's the thing
if we had antimatter bombs and were able
to
contain antimatter
you could have i was reading this thing
about it
a weapon the size of a standard icbm but
carrying an anti-matter explosive would
take out a quarter of the planet
now my math is probably wrong but i was
reading an article that said like the
amount of energy released from something
that powerful
they said
if there was an antimatter bomb the size
of you it would blow up one fourth of
the planet ripping the planet clean i
think it'd be a lot more than that or
don't i mean
if if you've got a football size of
plutonium
and then you slam
uranium into it or vice versa plutonium
well i mean there's different systems
with easy jacketed plastic explosive
the more primitive stuff they fire a
uranium bullet into plutonium they got a
bunch of systems but i mean man i mean
they're saying like a tiny bit of real
antimatter they were able to hold it
together with i mean that their estimate
sorry blow the sun up we're gonna go to
the member segment because we're gonna
let alex just say whatever he wants and
so i want to maximize the amount of time
we have for that but it's all
theoretical we're just sitting here
talking about all this stuff for sure
they don't want us to discuss and just
expand our minds into larger discussions
in areas but hey i just hope people will
understand we're still on the air ways
we're even bigger we ever were thanks to
all the fans and supporters and i've
made mistakes in the past i'll apologize
for them they'll use that against me but
we're alive and well at the dreaded evil
uh freeworldnews.tv where you find all
the videos
freeworldnews.tv it's one word and of
course uh
newswars.com and people should see what
we're actually saying and what we're
doing what like you're doing rather than
you know just lie and say oh he's a nazi
he did this he you know he did that
i want to show you something when we
start off the members podcast so make
sure you go to timcast.com i want to
want i've got a video from 10 years ago
that i want to i want you to uh i want i
want you to hear so again tbs.com member
segment
where we can just go completely off the
hook and it should be up
i would normally say 11 p.m but i have a
feeling we're gonna go long and we're
gonna have fun with it so again sign up
you can follow us you can follow me
personally at tim cast you can follow
the show at tim cast irl uh phil you
want to shout anything out uh i am full
that remains on twitter on
twitch on
i'm on mines basically uh just about
everywhere i feel that remains uh stream
monday tuesday thursday friday on twitch
um
yeah so um what do you think about this
so don't be mad at me for being
obnoxious i'm sorry
alex the last thing i feel towards you
is anger
i love you too
and by the way pool's having fun for the
people on the chats stop being mean to
him
don't worry my listeners are mean to me
too we've had them on we've had alex on
three times we don't we know
you having the courage to do that yeah i
mean if if we get it
courage is contagious my man we followed
all the rules a little off the rails for
a little bit
but you know if but that stuff also
sounds crazy let's let's let's let's do
it yeah sure hit me up with ian
crossland great conversation alex phil i
love you guys tim everybody
lydia love you lydia everybody tuning in
share with everybody to tune in to
the you know real free open area and
tell them to do it it creates the chain
reaction that's right that's true i feel
like i learn so much new stuff every
single time alex is on and i absolutely
love having him i'm not afraid to have
him on and uh happy to bring him back
thanks for having me yes absolutely the
illuminati wants you to cut your dick
off
i have
this is the live portion we're now going
to start recording the members podcast
you can find over at timcast.com so make
sure you go subscribe and share whatever
you can because uh that's the only way
we get we get past the sensors and you
know youtube props up cnn all stuff we
don't get those advantages so we rely on
you guys but timcast.com and we'll see
you there
you